this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all that ad
nauseam but now I am falling asleep in
record time why because I'm using a
device it was recommended to me by
friends called the Pod cover by eight
sleep the Pod cover fits on any mattress
and allows you to adjust the temperature
of your sleeping environment providing
the optimal temperature that gets you
the best night's sleep with the Pod
covers Dual Zone temperature control you
and your partner can set your sides of
the bed to as cool as 55 degrees or as
hot as 110 degrees I think generally in
my experience my partners prefer the
high side and I like to sleep very very
cool so stop fighting this helps based
on your Biometrics environment and sleep
stages the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wake-ups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its best-in-class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable so go to
eightsleep.com Tim for 300 off the Pod
cover through June 6th stay cool this
summer with eight sleep now shipping
within the US Canada the UK select
countries in the EU and Australia that's
eightsleep.com Tim spelled out
e-i-g-h-t-sleep.com Tim for 300 off
foreign
this episode is brought to you by
Aeropress I love Aeropress with more
than 45
000 5 Star reviews and customers in more
than 60 countries it might be the
highest rated coffee maker on the planet
let's rewind just a bit because back in
2010 2011 I tested the entire gamut of
coffee brewing and filtering options
alongside a former Barista world
champion this was for research for the
four-hour Chef that concluded with a
statement that the Aeropress was quote
Bar None my favorite Brewing method end
quote I even mentioned it and made a cup
of coffee on Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon using the Aeropress here is the
back back story remember the aerobi the
amazing ufo-like disc that you could
throw farther than a football field Alan
Adler a mechanical engineer and Stanford
University lecturer created that then
after Conquering the 1980s toy Market he
began to obsess over one thing coffee
the result was the Aeropress which
debuted in 2006 it was quickly adopted
by the specialty coffee community and it
became so popular with the Barista
community that someone in Oslo Norway
started a world Aeropress Championship
because the Aeropress combines the best
of three Brewing methods you get a cup
that is full bodied like a French press
smooth and complex as if you were using
a pour over method and rich in flavor
like espresso best of all it's super
small you can pack it in your bag when
you travel it takes literally five
seconds to clean it is all practical no
fuss and you don't have to drink
mediocre coffee at your office or Airbnb
and now they have a new crystal clear
version Sleek enough for display and
Tough Enough for the road you can pick
one up at aeropress.com Tim that's
a-e-r-o-p-r-e-s-s.com Tim for less than
fifty dollars that's aeropress.com Tim
and my listeners that's you guys can get
15 off just use the link aeropress.com
M I highly encourage you to try it out
you will not be disappointed
aeropress.com Tim optimal minimal at
this altitude I can run flat out for a
half mile before my hand starts shaking
can I answer your personal questions
[Music]
foreign
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job each and every episode to
deconstruct world-class performers from
all different disciplines to tease out
the best practices the exercises the
influences the books Etc that you can
apply to your own lives and my guest
today is Eric Cressy I've known Eric for
quite some time you can find him on
Twitter at Eric Cressy
c-r-e-s-s-e-y Eric cressie m-a-c-s-c-s
is President and co-founder of Cressy
Sports Performance with facilities in
Palm Beach Gardens Florida and Hudson
Massachusetts he has worked with clients
ranging from Youth Sports to the
professional and Olympic ranks but he is
best known for his very extensive work
with baseball players more than 100
professional players train at CSP each
offseason Eric also serves as director
of player health and performance for the
New York Yankees you may have heard of
them Eric double majored in extra
exercise science and Sports and Fitness
management at the University of New
England and then received his master's
degree in kinesiology with a
concentration in exercise science at the
University of Connecticut Cressi has
published books and video resources that
have been sold in more than 60 countries
he regularly lectures both nationally
and internationally and his research has
been published in the Journal of
strength and conditioning research he
serves as a consultant to New Balance
Proteus motion and athletic greens
Chrissy has a Blog and free newsletter
at his website ericcresty.com and has a
podcast at Elite
baseballpodcast.com you can find more
about his training facilities at
cressysportsperformance.com and on
social media Eric Cressy on Instagram
Twitter and elsewhere we'll link to all
of those in the show notes at tim.blog
podcast without further Ado please enjoy
a very practical a very tactical and
wide-ranging conversation with Eric
Cressy
Eric Dr Cressy nice to see you you too
thanks for having me absolutely and I
thought we could start with the personal
because I feel and this is not my quote
but the intensely personal is often the
most universal
and the way to lead into that is by
reading an email you sent to me this was
not too long ago but it led to this
conversation on the podcast hi Tim I
hope this email finds you well wonderful
to see your continued success with the
podcast thank you for that in particular
I love this section on medical literacy
in the recent episode with Peter attia
it's such an important concept that can
go in a number of different directions
but my brain immediately went to the
realm of Orthopedics
a few things that I think are must
covers include don't worry guys this is
not going to be the Great American novel
but these are the bullets got me very
excited to have a conversation that I
could share with people I was like I'm
going to have this conversation anyway
why don't we share with folks because I
think it'll be incredibly helpful number
one incidental findings on
musculoskeletal Imaging of asymptomatic
individuals we'll explain what that
means bias slash oversight in Radiology
we'll probably touch on all these three
the medical model potentially not being
well equipped to handle non-homogenous
conditions like low back pain so the
origin of this was my personal
experience of having this escalating low
back pain
that led to x-rays MRIs and to this
point in time it's been very hard to
decipher what is happening
back to the email number four systemic
causes of musculoskeletal pain in
parentheses vitamin D prescription meds
Etc five the overlooked misunderstood
emerging role of the fascial system six
psychosocial stress and sleep
deprivation as they relate to injury
risk seven New Frontiers in biologic
stem cell PRP Etc
I wanted to read this email in
particular for the close and some
phrasing in that and this is from you I
was always fascinated with a lot of
these things but over the past four
years with the Yankees my access to Aha
moments has been far greater it might
make for an intriguing episode that
would help folks advocate for themselves
a bit better that's self-advocation is
is super interesting to me and I thought
we would start with the low back pain
because I've learned so much in the last
month or two we can begin anywhere that
makes sense but actually before we get
to that just to establish some Bona
fides because people certainly have
heard the bio but what are some of your
PR's in the deadlift let's just begin
their personal records I pulled 660 at a
body weight of 181 a little bit lighter
at a body weight of 165 so I've lifted
my fair share of heavy stuff without a
really a well-targeted long-term goal
with it in mind now without
recommending this to other people many
years ago because we were introduced to
something around I don't know 2010 2012
in that range
you once sent me a video of you doing
something you would probably not advise
to any of your clients which was trap
bar deadlifts for higher reps with some
ungodly amount of weight for the Reps do
you recall what this might have looked
like I do I think it was 415 for 25 and
I made the mistake of doing it
Thanksgiving morning and uh absolutely
ruined the holiday I think I had a
headache for about four days so
um definitely one of my my more ignorant
moments in my youth all in the quest of
science though right on the quest of
science a man of the people and the
reason I want to bring this up is
because there are many theoreticians out
there
I am very interested in people who have
the academic and research understanding
of the literature but who are also
practitioners and that is certainly you
on many different levels so how should
we Edge our way into low back pain or do
you think it makes sense to start I
think back pain is is fascinating
obviously it's a it's an
all-encompassing diagnosis it covers a
lot of different things that that
impacts a lot of different people what's
particularly fascinating about it is
it's very different if you're a
nine-year-old kid and you fall off the
playground you break your form you throw
in a cast he heals up you're good to go
there's a much more significant level of
chronicity that happens with the back
pain that we see in the general
population and I think what's to my
email's point in the term
non-homogeneous was when I actually
stole from from Dr Stewart McGill who's
who's great in this and he's talked
about how the the medical system may not
actually be well designed to handle a
non-homogenous condition like meaning
widely varied exactly being different
yes or somewhat different you know
speaking in a you know really really
broad strokes and an athletic population
we tend to see much more extension-based
low back pain so we're going to see in a
tennis player or baseball player soccer
players probably markedly different than
what we're going to see is someone who
sat at a computer for 30 years or a roof
or a plumber or a floor who spent a lot
of time in flexion bending forward
correct and then what we have is we have
a lot of people that have probably done
a little bit of both and create
adaptations in both directions maybe
it's the plumber who goes out and then
plays in a wreck you know basketball
league four nights a week or something
like that so everyone presents I think
with a different history of activity and
symptoms and either successful or you
know failed treatments that may have
intervened in one way or another I mean
it often leaves us just like in this
situation where you can't just look at
these all the same let's maybe segue
just for a moment to Radiology which
people might raise an eyebrow over but
let me explain why the event that
precipitated me reaching out to you was
getting a radiologist report after an
MRI and I got the report court and it
was right before going to dinner I was
in an Uber I somehow got to be a text
which I thought was very interesting I
thought it was a phishing attack at
first but it turned out to be legitimate
and there was moderate to severe XYZ
this type of degeneration that type of
degeneration and as a layperson I'll be
at someone who's tried to take time to
become somewhat medically literate it
was a terrifying read from me personally
and the I think it's the Impressions
slash conclusion section as you pointed
out was a little strange usually there's
some type of summary but it effectively
just said see above
and as someone who doesn't read these
reports frequently I just took that at
face value that that's how these things
are generally formatted
and spoke with you spoke with Peter or
Tia and Dr Tia said to me on the phone
he said well if I were to show you an
MRI of my spine I think he keeps his
images somewhere close to his desk
he said it's a garbage fire basically it
makes your spine look like a neonate but
he is as far as I know asymptomatic does
not have any type of low back pain or
back pain
how should we think about
the use of these tools your experience
is not at all I hate to say it unique I
think it's very much something that
happens every day and let me preface
this by saying I'm not a radiologist I'm
not an orthopedic surgeon not a doctor
in any capacity I'm a strength Edition
coach so I kind of found this world by
accident I do happen to look at a couple
thousand Radiology reports every year
it's something that kind of happened by
accident just because you started to try
to work backwards from the conditions
that we were seeing people who are
having pain at various points in their
body and we want to understand why this
is not to take away from Radiologists or
doctors at all because it's a it's an
incredibly specialized you know approach
and it's a huge part of the diagnostic
puzzle but the thing that I would say
that's interesting first off is we'll
have people that'll walk in with you
know with their films and I'll say
listen I'm not reading those for you
people go to school for a decade to
understand how to do that but I can
certainly kind of draw maybe some
conclusions from some of the things that
you see relative to my sample size so I
always try to always illustrate that in
our conversations but the big picture I
would say is that it has to be looked as
a piece as the diagnostic puzzle so
really no Diagnostic Imaging is
appropriate without you know an
accompanying physical exam a full like
kind of case history as you go through a
variety of things because as we kind of
alluded to in that initial email it's
like there's a lot of things that can
impact it and what's really fascinating
maybe this is the place where it gets
intriguing for people is there's
actually an article that came out in the
Lancet in 2009 an exact quote from it
that said lumbar Imaging for low back
pain without indications of serious
underlying conditions does not improve
clinical outcomes clinicians should
refrain from routine immediate lumbar
Imaging in patients with acute or
sub-acute low back pain and without
features suggesting a serious underlying
condition so we've always been taught
the second something gets hurt you call
your doctor you go and you get an MRI
and you get all the answers and there
may absolutely be a case for that in
certain situations and there may also be
times where you get a whole bunch of
false positives they can wind up leading
you to bark up the wrong tree and it
happens a lot with spines how objective
are the these reports yeah I remember
WeChat on the phone and I want to say
that you mentioned if in some I wouldn't
know what to call them studies perhaps
experiments that if Radiologists were
shown photographs of the patient's faces
that the outcomes differ yeah there was
one particular study and I don't think
it's at all reflective of like a greater
conspiracy theory in the Radiology
community that but if patients pictures
were actually shown to the Radiologists
before reading they tended to read a
little bit more intently so I think it's
like anything else Radiology is a little
bit like Fine Art and they're ultimately
trying to interpret what they see and
sometimes you can see a little bit more
or a little bit less and sometimes if
you see something that's very slight you
might not relate it in a report whereas
other people might document you know
absolutely everything and the additional
contacts I would add to that is number
one I'm used to
duplicating tests to get a second
opinion before staging any kind of
intervention but I have much more
comfort with blood draws and those types
of biomarkers so if I see something
that's out of whack I don't immediately
freak out
I think well okay if my triglycerides
have shot up that significantly it's
probably some type of dietary issue
maybe I just ate a ton of meat the night
before and I had it too late Etc or it
could be a lab error and I'll run the
test again and only when you have
confirmation what I consider beginning
to Stage interventions I have less
exposure to MRIS
so it threw me into a complete tizzy
right I mean I I really was scared of
this because it seemed also maybe unlike
the blood markers like something
structural I could not
fix potentially without some kind of
surgery and whether it's objective or
not and I have the number of friends who
are Radiologists and very very good at
what they do
it's incredibly difficult skill to
develop and that being as it may
the aspect of low back pain
that is different from my past injuries
because as you know I've had a long list
of injuries if I let's just say really
hurt my shoulder really hurt my knee
really hurt my ankle I've done all these
things and I get an MRI ultimately the
correlation
from image read to pain seems to be much
stronger than with the low back whereas
with the low back it's like you have
people who might have what appear to be
normal images but they're extremely
symptomatic they have all sorts of pain
showing up and vice versa
so how do you begin to
examine or fix low back pain
that's a very definition of a billion
dollar question I mean just to speak to
some of the things that you just kind of
hinted at in terms of actual numbers
there was actually a landmark study in
the New England Journal medicine they
basically looked at a collection of
asymptomatic spines I believe there were
98 particular subjects 52 percent of
them had a disc bulge at one level 27
had a protrusion and one percent had an
extrusion so 82 percent of people had
something on and actually 38 of them had
abnormalities at more than one level
without having in front of me your
report was markedly more significantly
than that we saw quite a bit more and
that was looking at a relatively
unathletic population and you look at
yourself like you've got a history in a
wide variety of sports you've tried just
about everything and when I saw yours I
started thinking more there was actually
studying the American Journal of
Medicine that came out in 2000 that
looked at Elite Spanish athletes and
they're actually scoping especially for
stress fractures and what was
interesting is they found eight percent
of a Spanish athletes were affected and
only 50 percent of them really
demonstrated symptoms so really you're
looking at a scenario or one out of 21
out of 25 actually had a stress fracture
they had no idea that was there they saw
it a lot in track and field throwers and
rowers and gymnasts and weight lifters
but when I saw that study I didn't buy
it in an American population just
because weightlifting is much more
accepted here we see way more early
Sports specialization here we see more
rotational sports hockey obviously
lacrosse baseball you know everything's
just played at a much higher level so
and I think that study was also you know
it was done in 23 years ago so I think
right now we are dealing with an
epidemic of a lot of young athletes that
always have stress fractures taking
place every time I see an oblique strain
on a professional baseball player
there's usually an old stress fracture
you know listed on the Radiology report
that they just saw so for a guy like you
it's a unique look because you know you
have a wide variety of things that could
be emerging and and certainly when you
got your report read they talked about
absolutely everything that was on there
right and then I was sitting at dinner
trying to concentrate but my inner voice
was going I think you feel tingling your
low back I think there's burning in your
toes I think your foot is numb I'm
freaking out which is unlike me
but it took having a conversation with
you just to think about how
compartmentalized my reference points
are a conversation with you to do maybe
what in retrospect is obvious which is
send the images to somebody else don't
send the report because that's the
interpretation but get a second read
which is what I'm doing right now how
should we think about low back pain
whether it's preventative or diagnosing
we can go in any direction that you
think makes sense yeah I mean I think
the first thing I'll say is that we
probably have been conditioned to think
that it is all the same and it really
isn't you know what we see in a
sedentary population is generally going
to be markedly different than what we
encount in our very athletic population
particularly those that utilize strength
and conditioning on top of sports
participation so it's one thing to just
be an Olympic lifter it's nothing
altogether to Olympic lift and then go
play you know soccer or something like
that so I think we have to really
understand our population Norm for sure
yeah I remember you asked me on the
phone you said or asked
if I thought I was
compression sensitive
flexion sensitive or extension sensitive
is that right yeah good remember yeah
and so
extension bending backwards like a
backbend let's just say I'm simplifying
this of course flexion like yoga bending
over at the waist rounding your spine
and then compression which I knew
immediately I was going to be sensitive
to because I think the the test don't do
this at Home Folks work with a
professional this is not medical advice
but was to raise up my heels and kind of
like a classic heel stomp test he'll
stop test and I was like nope I don't
even want to do that because I know it's
going to hurt those are tough ones
because your our head's way more than
bowling balls we're always encountering
compression in our daily life and some
of those are some of the most you know
stubborn cases of back pain but I think
in the big picture you talked about like
you know freaking out over an MRI right
I'm not proud of it yeah but it's like
it's like looking at your business right
and you had one employee that had a bad
day showed up late for work or something
like that and you meet like I think oh
my God my business is falling apart in
reality it's it's one little entity
might be wildly profitable and a million
things are going right so you have to be
careful about honing in on one aspect of
that diagnostic equation so I talk a lot
more about not just having a medical
diagnosis but also having a movement
diagnosis having an ability to relate
how you move to what's actually taking
place next to your symptoms so let's
talk about that because as always with
my very self-interested podcast
I wanted to have this conversation
because I think it would be very helpful
for folks who are trying to navigate
this type of
non-homogenous condition
I just like using big words and I also
wanted you to have a chance to
look at my movement to look at
my current state to see if you can
discern anything about the low back so
what might a movement screen or an
assessment look like what are some of
the things that you take someone through
the first thing I'll say is it always
starts with a with a conversation and I
think that's really really overlooked
unfortunately nowadays because if
there's one thing I've learned over the
course of my career it's that people
always under report even if you look
like facial manipulation which is a
prominent you know soft tissue
intervention right now they'll dig deep
on hey did you break your ankle when
you're younger or anything like that so
it can really open some some eyes for
you and I've had it several times in my
career where I've been burned by by not
digging deeper are you you look at a guy
he's like yeah you know it just doesn't
make sense and yeah I fractured my
scapula in a car accident ten years ago
do you want to give an example on the
prescription medside because people
might think it's unrelated so they don't
report it but yeah whether Accutane or
something else yeah that is one that we
if there's one we see the most commonly
particularly because of our work with
young athletes is you know see athletes
that are taking acne medication and
don't necessarily want to report it's a
sensitive subject right and oftentimes
you do a postural screen they take their
shirt off and they have significant acne
that's readily apparent but you know
some that stuff can say in your system
for a while and there can be some
pronounced you know musculoskeletal side
effects in terms of joint pain and
things like that so we've seen a number
of athletes over the years that have
done well as they've gotten away from it
but we've also seen scenarios where they
didn't report it and you know we
floundered with kind of the wrong
approaches for three or four months
before it finally just came up in
conversation you know in the general
population certainly there's there's
concerns you guys spoke on your podcast
about Statin use you know some people do
have really significant muscle soreness
with that I mean seeing certain
antibiotics that may make people more
susceptible to tendon injuries as well
Cipro yeah that's one that's been
discussed for sure so it just speaks to
you always have to dig deeper on it and
people really tend to under report you
know pharmacological interventions they
under report previous musculoskeletal
injuries and I think they also under
report what they might not know do you
know if this person is wildly deficient
in vitamin D or they haven't added with
magnesium levels there can be so many
different places where things can kind
of go off the rail systemically that I
think it's just so important to always
start with a conversation and also get a
feel for their history with exercise and
in some cases Rehabilitation what's
worked what hasn't what's made you feel
better or you felt great with dry
needling but not with something else
those are all things that can kind of
Clue Into the you know the clinical
puzzle so to speak yeah totally if
somebody's
let's just say uh Jiu Jitsu player and
they're constantly in guard that's gonna
be very different from say a surfer who
spends 90 of their time paddling in that
extension so you have the conversation
what happens after that I always go to a
static postural assessment and there's a
lot of I guess debate over posture and
it doesn't perfectly predict injury or
lack thereof but it does give us some
Clues into where people at least start
and you know there are schools of
thought that are heavily focused on
alignment the idea being if you're in a
good alignment it's going to increase
the likelihood you're going to be in a
better position once you actually wind
up somewhere else I look at it much more
how's gravity working on this body what
are the shapes that they're in it starts
to give me some Clues on hey if you've
got really really low shoulders you got
this downslope shoulder blade like crazy
and you have anterior shoulder pain I'm
probably thinking that when we get to
movement you know your scapular upward
rotation what's taking place when you
take your arms overhead probably is
going to be less than ideal just because
you're starting 10 yards behind the
starting race
the other fly in the ointment for me is
that I have
congenital transitional vertebra well I
should say vertebrae what is the plural
vertebra is the singular I guess so I
have one transitional segment which
means for people who may wonder if
you're looking at my lumbar spines my
lower back on an MRI from the side
these segments of the spine should and
I'm simplifying here but look kind of
rectangular and in my case I have one
vertebra in the lower back that is more
like a wedge it's like a door wedge
so I have a lot of lower back lordosis
right I have sway back basically I used
to have kyphosis which was that like
Hunchback look
thankfully fix that but that is also
another
[Music]
that's another aspect to this whole
thing which has led it to be a problem
for decades it's true for my brother as
well but then whatever it was 12 weeks
ago suddenly everything just got put
into acceleration mode from Pain
perspective and it's really been
mystifying and it's made me really
sympathize for people in chronic pain
because it seems to be such an elusive
problem for so many people
so you look at the static posture what
comes next I mean to your point
everybody's Invincible until they're not
right you know and I think that's that's
a line I tend to use quite a bit but you
might have that conversation about hey I
have a congenital variant in some way
some people we see in the structure of
their hips or it could be a number of
different things but what you also have
to do is you have conversations with
doctors with physical therapists to see
if their symptoms actually correlate
where that may take place and that's
something I should emphasize is that I
work as part of a comprehensive team I
have physical therapist one door down
and massage therapists and we refer out
to a lot of orthos on the regular but
once we've done that postural screen you
know for me I will go into a collection
of like I guess classic Orthopedic range
of motion tests we may do some manual
muscle testing and then we actually get
them up and move them around in more
General screens things like overhead
squats overhead lunge walks push-ups toe
touches
shoulder abduction slash flexion all
these different screens that are I guess
collectively General screens so you want
a collection of both General and
specific screens that you're not
necessarily missing things I got it so
General screen but you're also doing
specific screens that might relate to
the lower back correct assessment yeah
and those are your your gateways right
in my world those are sometimes just the
things that I need to know and whether
hey we need to refer this out yeah
because you're gonna have people that
walk in with low back pain that just
they train like idiots they either
choose the wrong exercises Who you
calling me or are they going the wrong
uh they go in the wrong patterns or
whatever it is so they some people just
need good coaching and maybe a little
break maybe they need a discussion about
okay the volume in your program is just
inappropriate we need to find some
different kind of variability for you
and then other people they kind of
scream this is something much more
clinical we need to escalate this we
need to get it to the hands of somebody
who could do some Imaging for it and
maybe get a better diagnosis or we may
in-house do some kind of test retest
where it's hey let's do some manual
therapy here and let's see if they get
some symptomatic resolution and if we do
create some kind of a transient change
whether it's in the context of the range
of motion or in the reduction of
symptoms what are some things on the
exercise side of things that we can do
to follow it up to make those changes
stick
is there a resource or a book anything
that people could check out to become
familiar with some of these movement
screens long time ago I talked about FMS
in the four-hour body there are probably
many other variants of that type of
screen with the understanding that you
should work with a professional are
there any other
resources you might recommend yeah for
sure and I think the the crude FMS has
done a good job and the selective
functional movement assessment is kind
of a little bit more of a clinical
add-on to that that I think they've done
a good job with that if you walk in and
look at our screen it's really a
collection of different philosophies all
melded together so I think my response
would probably be very different for
people in the Health and Human
Performance Industries asking versus
like a general population folk with that
said I know Kelly and Juliet Starr at in
their new book have kind of talked about
some stuff he was a recent guest just
you know things that people should be
able to accomplish in terms of
activities of daily living and tasks I
do think that's all maybe a good
proactive screen that people could use
built to move great just finished it
so people can start there let's continue
to go down the rabbit hole of lower back
pain so I'm looking at some research
that
I gathered for this conversation
could you speak to maybe some of the
ingredients in the cocktail that can
produce
lower back pain or exacerbate lower back
pain so I have a number of things here I
didn't want to read them in depth and
maybe you have a revised your thinking
on this but I have a whole list of
things here left AIC right BC patterning
no idea what that is poor motor control
and strength of the glutes poor hip
rotation of mobility in general thoracic
spine Mobility Etc are there any Usual
Suspects that in
not necessarily sedentary folks but
let's just make this personal because
that's the easiest way to have a
conversation you have a former
competitive athlete me and I've done a
fair amount of extension and flexion but
I'd say probably more flexion just from
wrestling yeah and so on
and I have not competed in a long time
but I've continued with the weight
training and sometimes more methodical
than other times what are some of the
ingredients that you would want to
consider as part of the cocktail that is
producing the lower back pain I can't
remember when I wrote that but it's a
good find in the archives yeah I think
the big things that I would say is is
all those things come back to probably
two things it's loading aberrant
patterns so you know an example of the
left AIC right BC patterning that speaks
to the posture restoration Institute and
they talk about a very predictable
pattern of asymmetry you know right hips
that are shifted out low right shoulders
and so there can be some compensatory
things when we start to to load what
does that mean left AIC it's just an
abbreviation for the pattern they talk
about I see but basically that's the way
they Define it and you will see it very
commonly if you go to any major league
baseball game you'll see every shortstop
standing between pitches like in the
exact same position they'll be stuck in
their right hip with a low right
shoulder and their mindset has always
been that we'd rather breathe well and
move poorly than move well and not be
able to breathe it's a survival Instinct
and yeah to some degree these patterns
that we account for or how we maintain
our line of sight and our ability to
breathe the way that we want to so you
know these are normally so symmetries
right we have a heart we have a vena
cave on one side and a liver on the
other side but when we get into trouble
is where these things may become
excessive and we load on top of them and
we lose the variability that we count on
to have long-term successful movement
and I think that's what leads kind of my
second point is that when we talk about
poor hip rotation poor thorac's my
Mobility really where people get into
trouble is they sell out for too much
movement at one joint what do you mean
by that so if you look at how your spine
is constructed as an example look at
your lumbar spine they're very big
vertebral segments they're really
conditioned much more for handling
compression they don't rotate nearly as
much as you go further up your spine you
have substantially smaller segments that
are way more equipped for rotational
capacity and I think that just speaks to
our body's wonderful design is that we
need to get a lot of rotation through
our hips and a lot of rotation through
our mid back our thrust one and
certainly our cervical spine as well and
we don't necessarily have it sometimes
we go to the wrong places to get it and
that's why some people will wind up with
back pain what would be some of the
wrong places
the lumbar spine in particular oh I see
rotating at the lumbar correct basically
using the molars of the back to rotate
that's exactly it and you get into
trouble when you bang those big segments
off of one another you can wind up with
a collection of different issues and you
know Stu McGill has done some great
stuff in his research where he's talked
about spine range of motion particularly
lumbar spine range of motion being
positively correlated with injury risk
yeah it has to move but it just can't
move to it there is such a thing as
hypermobility exactly and I think the
challenge that we see sometimes is how
people change over the course of time so
you know I talked in that article about
poor hip mobility and we know is that
some athletes over the course of time
will develop reactive changes in their
hip
now does poor hip mobility in this
context mean hip extension sort of the
freeze frame of the Sprinter with one
leg behind them or does it mean
something else I think it can be all the
above you know if you look at a lack of
hip and turn rotation it seems to be
associated with low back pain and
golfers so I think it depends on what
your activity is but I would argue that
not having sufficient hip flexion can
create problems too I think it's a joint
that obviously has evolved from
evolutionary standpoint from being very
very mobile to being a little bit more
stable to support weight-bearing but
where we get into trouble as we start to
lay down you know a lot of bony
overgrowth on the acetabulum so the
socket or on the head of the femur and
those can create a collection of
challenges because you have stiffness
that you have a hard time working around
so at the end of the day it all comes
back to we lose variability over the
course of time we lose the ability to go
back to what's very foundational for us
so I'd love to chat maybe about thoracic
mobility in a second just to do a deep
dive on one of these
first I want to say and you can fact
check me on this just for people
listening who may suffer from low back
pain or back pain or actually it's a
question what percentage of your super
high performing players
if you were to take an MRI of their back
have what would be viewed as something
pathological or deterioration 100 100
and the best example I can give you this
is with knees 2020 study of 115 patients
average age was 44 so 230 total knees
MRI showed abnormalities in 97 of nice
30 percent of them have meniscal tears
it's 57 had cartilage abnormalities 46
percent had tendon abnormalities and six
percent of them were actually qualifying
as high grade tendinopathy they had some
ligament disruptures in there two
percent of them had ACL issues that they
didn't even know were there and so these
are 44 year olds and this wasn't really
an athletic population so you can
imagine the wear and tear that takes
place from playing any sport at a really
high level and you can do this for every
joint in the body it's it's pretty
eye-opening and when I reached out to
Kelly Starr at the co-author of the most
recent built to move that you mentioned
about the same MRI read because I was
like okay Defcon five need to figure
this out especially before I go
traveling internationally and won't have
won't have access to much and his rough
reply I'm paraphrasing here but you
might recall some of this he said you
know all that says is you're a Savage
who's played Sports really intensely
he's like guess what if I sent you a
photo of your face from when you were 15
and then compared it to your face now
you've aged that's true for your back
too rub some dirt he's like it's gonna
be fine
don't forget and then he sent me a
photograph of something that was removed
from his knee I can't remember what it
was and he's like that's supposed to be
flat and it was just so mangled mess and
he's like yeah now I'm back to full
operating capacity and just your point I
think normalizing it a little bit for
folks to say hey this is super common
and it's just part of being doesn't mean
insignificant but part of the discussion
another study that I talk about a lot
with our athletes so there was a study
of Scandinavian junior basketball
players and this is significant because
we're talking about a collection of
basketball players in their late teens
like these are the guys that can recover
from anything I'm in my 40s I can't
bounce back from the dumb stuff I used
to they looked at 134 players 268
tenants and this is where it gets really
fascinating there's only 19 tenants so
seven percent of them actually presented
clinically with like a patellar
tendinopathy they said the front of my
knee hurts and then what they did was
they went back and they ultrasounded all
268 tens and they found that under
ultrasound 26 of all tendons could be
diagnosed with tendinopathy so they hit
the clinical qualifying criteria for a
Tenon problem so you can make the
argument that for every one we diagnose
there's probably three that get
overlooked and it's probably
substantially higher both these numbers
probably shift as we get older and older
and that to me is just so important is
you almost have to look at your
musculoskeletal Health as there's a line
it's a symptomatic threshold line I'm
either above it or below it it's kind of
like being Right On The Fringe of having
like a type 2 diabetes diagnosis you go
for a walk you watch what you based on
my cookies last night I think I might be
there exactly that was a veiled cookies
reference
but I think what we look at is everyone
to some degree is probably working right
at that threshold and maybe it's because
some of those Imaging findings are
significant but it's our job to figure
out what can we do with our movement
diagnosis what is it that we see and how
they move whether it's a hip rotation
limitation or a lack of scapular upward
rotation or poor cervical spine motion
whatever it is what are the things that
we can do in our training interventions
both in terms of what we do and what we
don't do to keep people below those
symptomatic thresholds and it's not even
just an exercise thing sometimes it's a
you know we've all had that friend who
got Dairy out of his life and it changed
his life or someone was legitimately
intolerant to gluten that had serious
problems with that and so sometimes it's
a systemic intervention as much it is it
is like a true you know training or
Rehabilitation intervention
foreign
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
ag1 by athletic greens I get asked all
the time what I would take if I could
only take one supplement the answer is
invariably ag1 I view it as my
all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it long ago in my 2010
number one New York Times bestseller the
four hour body and I did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin a
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and immune
support formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens ag-1 makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when good Whole Foods
simply aren't at hand or when you just
want to ensure you are covering your
bases ag-1 is the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop and athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first subscription purchase go to
athleticgreens.com Tim you can check it
out athleticgreens.com Tim they also
offer a 90-day money-back guarantee if
you are not 100 satisfied learn more try
it out athleticgreens.com Tim
foreign
so let's take the limited thoracic
Mobility please feel free to fine tune
this but let's just call it mid back to
Mid back yeah just for Simplicity so
people know what we're talking about a
lot of folks listening spend a lot of
time at computers probably not getting
much rotation what would the training
look like if you diagnose someone with
very poor thoracic Mobility what might
some of the training look like to
address that the first thing is I would
say make sure that you're separating
stack posture from movement proficiency
and we see very different things in an
athletic population versus a desk pound
population a dustbump population you're
asking to see people similar to older
adults who acquire you know more of a
hunchback posture that kyphosis in
athletic population we actually see a
lot of very flat thoracic spines we see
people who are almost like in a military
posture from extending and rotating so
much and that actually creates a
scenario where we need to do a lot more
reaching and rounding and rotating to
drive flexion so in my baseball guys we
spend a lot of time talking about that
could you say that one more time talking
about what guys sort of yeah so we're
talking about the upper back you know I
think the assumption is that everybody
is very cyphotic meaning that we have
like that classic s-curve where we round
up top and then we Arch further down and
that's how we're built but we can
acquire different positions in different
places right so if you sit at a computer
all day you're gonna more than likely
reaffirm that it's going to get
significantly worse in an athletic
population what's interesting is
athletes extend they rotate they
actually arch their up upper back so
much that they move in the exact
opposite direction and they actually
lose the convex concave relationship
between the rib cage and the scapula so
in our baseball World we actually do the
exact opposite in many cases of what
we'll do with a lot of our people or
maybe the folks you're referring to the
folks that sit at a computer a lot well
let's take the computer folks yes
because that's going to be the majority
yeah what might you prescribe in that
situation I think the number one thing
that I'm looking for is I'm looking at
that upper back posture as an Avenue
through which I can create movement and
in particular rotation historically
speaking if you're really rounded
through your upper back it's not going
to rotate very well if you just look at
the way that the segments kind of sit on
each other try to do a pirouette while
you're bent over the waist exactly so
you know I think the challenges a lot of
people go to the gym and they do things
that reaffirm it they ride the bike they
bench press they do a lot of things that
just kind of support that existing
posture so do a whole bunch of cycling
exactly reinforce this computer posture
and then on top of that they may select
exercises that don't allow them to
safely get out of that posture so
classic example is the guy that sits
like that at a computer all day and he
goes to the gym he tries to overhead
press and his shoulder starts to bark at
him it's nothing inherently wrong with
overhead pressing but he might not have
the proficiency to even get enough
thoracic extension to safely get
overhead yeah just a quick side note one
of my very close friends has this habit
his proportions are a little unusual
former World Championship level
kickboxer
but the way he
historically has worked at his computer
is kind of slouching back on a couch so
his head is really crane forward
and he was totally fine until he wasn't
where he went from that posture for like
eight hours to playing a game of tennis
after work did a couple serves and then
had two plus years of
horrifying neck pain just bending the
paper clip into sort of Rangers of
motion where you don't have yeah and
think of what happened is that's just is
robbing Peter to pay Paul right if your
upper back doesn't move something else
has to pay the price maybe it's his
cervical spine that was put into
positions that were less than ideal a
lot of times we see a scapula just
doesn't sit flush with the rib cage the
way that it should so let's say you have
somebody who has developed a bit of the
Quasimodo back yeah where do you start
the first thing I that I'm going to try
to do is I'm going to try to safely give
them movement variability so things like
you know the old kind of adage of pull
twice as much as you push there may be
some Merit to it in that population I
get them more that when I'm doing my
pulling I'm actually doing a lot of
stuff that's probably unilateral so one
arm at a time and the reason I would do
that is I want to be reaching with the
opposite arm so I want to kind of bring
everything back to almost ambulation
like that reciprocal action that takes
place during the gate cycle could you
give an example of pulling and then
pushing or extending exactly something
like a cable row where you just do it
one arm at a time in the standing
position if you're rowing with the right
arm you would actually be reaching
forward with the left so you're actually
in the process you're not just moving
your shoulder blend on your rib cage
what you're actually doing is you're
teaching your thoracic spine to rotate a
little bit more so we find ourselves
trying to attack rotation I think more
and more across the board with our
clients just because it is the thing
that seems to go away even people that
lift through a full range of motion and
live what we think are really varied
lives like you look at them and they
often lose t-spine Mobility they lose
hip rotation over the course of time
maybe that's just where life takes us
you know we don't run as fast we don't
you know do as many athletic things into
our 40s but it's been impactful for
folks yes a t-spine is thoracic folks
what are some other tools or exercises
that you might consider for somebody
who's
mostly desk bound which is a lot of
people including me right now I would
say like even if you are training every
day it's like okay well you have I think
you've written before it's like you have
two hours to get it right in like
another 16 to 20 hours to get it wrong
absolutely what might you inject into
the program yeah the first thing I would
say is amplitude and maybe I got ahead
of myself by talking about the rose
because that's a it's a loaded movement
right I think probably what's more
important and we look at like the
long-term successful folks that really
do make significant changes not just to
their posture but probably more
importantly to their movement quality
it's using the warm-ups to actually
impart some kind of favorable change to
the way people move so instead of just
getting your body temperature up riding
the bike for five minutes the play is
more often than not to find ways to
expose yourself to new movement patterns
so for some of our folks there may be
like an element of self-mile fashion
release whether that's using a lacrosse
ball or an accumobility ball or foam
rolling or something to that effect and
then following it up we may do some
positional breathing just to kind of
teach different ways that they can get
expansion through their rib cage which
which can help them to optimize some of
their Mobility through their t-spine for
sure and then following it up with
larger amplitude movements when I say
amplitude I mean add range of motion
stuff that you don't get in your daily
life we look at people that work on
Factory lines that do the same thing
over and over again they wind up with
these pattern overload things but if we
give them exposure to more significant
ranges of motion they do substantially
better and it's probably something
that's mediated through the fascial
system we look at all these fascial
chains in our body everything starts at
our hands our feet and our head and if
we're really stuck in a small amplitude
movement for an extended period of time
meaning shorter range of movement
correct yeah exactly and you know Thomas
Myers who's the author of anatomy trains
or a distinctly remember a conversation
with him he spoke at a Commerce back in
2009 you know at the end of the
conference I remember chatting with him
and he said you know we probably know
about 25 percent of what we need to know
about the fascial system and you listed
off you know a few different things that
he thought were really important for
facial Fitness and really the biggest
things were multi-joint movements and be
patient those are the two things that he
emphasized over and over again and I may
have 28 year old daughters and a
four-year-old and they do everything
imaginable one of them like sits upside
down while she's reading every walk
across the living room has to include a
cartwheel they are craving movement
variability in every aspect of their
life and over the course of time we just
lose that whether it's long car rides or
you know different things that we do
like you didn't see my cartwheels after
the cookies last night exactly you know
I think sometimes a loss of athletic
participation right it's very structured
in our world from up until age 18 in
many cases and then people you know they
go off to college they get jobs whatever
it is and unless you're joining like a
men's soccer league every you know
Saturday afternoon or something like
that it's not there and I do think
there's something to be said about folks
trying not to lose that amplitude in
their lives and we even see it in higher
level Sports I work in baseball and you
know if you're a starting pitcher you
want every pitch to look exactly the
same where you get into trouble is when
there's deviations and hitters see it
differently so there's an unyielding
level of specificity in the baseball
world that needs to be I guess supported
by training that adds varied range of
motion to people's daily lives let's
expand on the fascial manipulation and
then I think I might want to come back
to exercises yeah just to paint a
picture for actionable stuff that people
might consider you talked about the row
but other examples of
increasing range of motion amplitude so
we could do that in either order do you
want to hit that first or do you want to
go straight to
fascial
matters professional talking exercise
stuff since we're kind of touching on a
list you know I think another thing
that's really really helpful is anything
that that allows your your shoulder
blade to move freely in space so you
think about if I have you going and do a
bench press you lay on your back your
shoulder blades are kind of tugged down
underneath you and in fact the way that
we coach high level benching is pinch
your scaps down and back in the real
world when you reach your shoulder bed
actually has to move around your rib
cage it effectively delivers your arm
that comes from thoracic rotation to the
upper back rotates which moves the rib
cage the scap of the moves on the rib
cage then the arm moves and when we're
stuck down on a bench it's not
necessarily a truly functional movement
and it might be great for Aesthetics and
it might be great because you you know
you like to bench press That's a
transverse or X arms are practical and
all so whenever possible I try to
emphasize things like push-ups cable
presses I love landmine presses so let's
talk about these so push-ups are you
talking
getting into more of a hollow back
position or just a flat position I
prefer the hollowed back position we'll
actually call them yoga push-ups some
people call it push-ups to downward dog
but I think those are great options for
driving some scapular upward rotation
and and really I kind of hinted at that
convex concave relationship of this Gap
and the rib cage that's so important to
really reaffirm what were the other two
that you mentioned any kind of cable
process where you're in the standing
position and you may be pressing away
from a cable column and some of the same
ideas of opposite arm reach can be
really helpful I got it so these are
alternating arms yeah exactly and so
it'd be sort of like a
I got this right unilateral Hammer press
it's about with cables yeah sure and
then the landmine was the last what is
that uh imagine a barbell stuck in a
corner they actually have you know
that's an overhead correct yeah and it
is and it isn't it's interesting you'll
see a lot of people that can't handle
overhead pressing and they do great with
landmine options and you can do so many
different variations on it and there's
the landmine from a half kneeling
position you can go half kneeling split
stance standing we'll do step throughs
we'll do rotational ones there's a
couple different attachments that you
can use tons of stuff I mean quick
Google search will find you a million
things on Instagram and on YouTube for
better for worse right what are the
benefits of landmine presses I think
above all else it's the free scapula of
pressing your shoulder blade is able to
move freely whereas it's not locked to a
bench like you would with a bench press
but I think beyond that there's
something to be said about it it's
almost like a calculated way to get some
axial loading you know some of the same
could you define axial yeah so when we
deadlift when we squat there's a
significant amount of load that goes
through our spine and some people don't
handle that really really well and I'd
argue you're probably a guy like that
right now I may be one of those yeah you
probably could could land mine press I
know for me personally I don't handle
really really heavy overhead pressing
great with my own shoulder history but
actually in my low back that bothers me
with video red interesting more than my
shoulders one more thing we got to
unpack when we finally look at you yeah
even though I had my left shoulder
completely reconstructed my shoulders
are still better sometimes where you
have to look deeper as you look back at
the injury history is you know maybe
there's a Mobility restriction a loss of
thoracic rotation from you know wearing
a sling after a surgery these are all
things you have to unpack but landmines
are awesome you use them with our
general pop folks with our with our
athletes a ton it's just kind of like a
it's a moderated overhead press is the
way I would look at it so definitely an
important tool in the in the training
toolbox do you use weighted rotational
exercises like chop and lift with cables
or some variant of that yeah we do this
quite a bit both chops and lifts we
throw mad balls a ton we use something
called the Proteus which is a cool
technology it's kind of purely
concentric that allows you to train some
of those patterns in the fluid way why
is that meaningful so for folks who may
Wonder please grab me if I'm heading
this wrong but if you imagine doing a
bicep curl because most people know what
a curl is the concentric would be the
positive portion when you are lifting
the weight The Eccentric would be the
lowering of the weight where you're sort
of lengthening the overlap of the fibers
why is the concentric Focus helpful I
think it's important in part because you
can do more of it you can do a high
volume of concentric work and it won't
necessarily make you sore so it can be
advantageous for athletes who are in
season but there are you know scenarios
in our daily lives where we do have kind
of purely concentric stuff think of like
you know lifting a couch to help your
friend move to a new apartment or
something like that or just you know
things that we do with Med ball if you
look at like some of the athletic
activities that we encounter like you
know kicking a soccer ball is largely a
concentric motion there's going to be
some elements of deceleration I mean
Sports there's a ton of concentric only
yeah but it's you know there is a high
velocity component so when you throw a
baseball there's actually a ton of
deceleration taking place throughout the
entire system but it is a concentric
dominant sport so I'm just going and
training the opposite direction doesn't
actually match up from like a pure
loading and velocity standpoint
okay so I feel like we've checked the
tick box of a number of exercises that
people might find helpful of course with
the help of a professional
fascia
let's talk about it yeah there's a lot
to talk about there is and probably get
some death threats from people that
listen people are crazy out there it's
wild yes
in politics and the fascial system are
kind of like uh three big things I saw
you posted the picture of some cupping
that you had recently and you got
eviscerated for like a better time yeah
and then I followed it up with saying
this is the Rorschach test for people on
the internet with strong opinions
because I didn't even provide any
context yet right people didn't even ask
what I was using it for but the
conviction and the rage was impressive
so maybe you could just start from the
basics and explain what fascia is
and then we can go from there the best
way I can describe is all the first time
I ever sat on a surgery I sat on an
elbow surgery okay and for those you
don't know Tommy John surgery is a most
you know kind of storied surgery in the
baseball world it's a tiny ligament on
the inside of the elbow and it's a
limiter right it's subjected to crazy
high stresses at super high velocities
and the fastest motion all of sports
which is the baseball throw and what
basically happens is that ligament when
it's ruptured needs to be repaired so
basically they'll you know basically
take a graft either from your form or
from your leg and they'll use to take a
tendon and make a ligament but what
happens is they have to do an incision
on the inside of your elbow so they open
you up and when you open it up you're
expecting to see this pristine anatomy
chart the first time you're there we all
took you know exercise physiology
Anatomy all that stuff and I even had
gross anatomy during my undergraduate
experience I spent a much time with
cadavers and it still didn't prepare me
for this but they have muscles they have
tendons they have bones they have
ligaments they have nerves that's the
stuff you expect to see but when they
actually cut that elbow open for the
first time you're like holy cow what is
is all this stuff it's the fascia senior
muscular septum and a ligament is
intramuscular yes septum exactly yeah
I'm throwing big words I don't know I
love you to slow this down so you go all
the way down I'm going to use it
correctly tomorrow I can't wait yeah and
what you're looking at very quickly is
like there's a lot of stuff to get
through because the ligament connects
bone to bone so you see all these
different layers what is all this stuff
in the way that wasn't in any means
anatomy chart and Visually what does it
look like is it kind of like spider webs
that's a great way to describe it yeah
and the hard part is when I got gross
anatomy a lot of it had been cut away
because they were teaching you muscle
you know we were the exercise science
students the med students and the
OTS and the athletic trainers they all
got it before we did so we missed out on
that the hard part about that world
though is it's very very important in
terms of as we're learning kind of how
it both restricts or optimizes Mobility
how it helps us to transfer force and
the best way I can describe it is we've
all seen that freaky athletic high
jumper who just doesn't look very strong
but jumps out of the gym we see baseball
players in our world there's a home guys
that throw 100 miles an hour that weigh
you know 160 170 pounds it just doesn't
make sense these are very fastly driven
athletes they're not producing high
levels of force with classic muscular
strength if you looked at like a Mark
Maguire back in the day McGuire is a
very strong guy it looked like the ball
just sat on his Bat for a while he
muscled it out of the park and you look
at other guys who had just freakish bat
speed that you know were very elastic in
nature Dan paff is a great coach she
talks about mechanically and fashionally
driven athletes our fashionally driven
athletes largely use this kind of
connective tissue Matrix to really
effectively transfer force and I think
you can fine tune it much like a whip
you know some people are really really
good at one activity I'm a guy who was
good at picking up heavy things off the
floor but I wasn't a great overhead
presser so I think we get what we train
and the fascial system is probably one
reason why
what are and this is waiting in a
dangerous territory but misconceptions
about the fascial system or
some of the most interesting modalities
of manipulating the fascial system that
you've seen good outcomes from with your
athletes yeah full disclosure I am not a
massage therapist or a physical
therapist or even athletic attorney so
it's outside of my scope of practice to
actually do manual therapy yeah but just
what you've seen I'm fortunate to work
with some really really good ones my
business partner Shane in Florida is
phenomenal is see some really high
profile athletes and on a regular basis
I see people that walk out of his office
shocked at how good they feel and I
think what do we have in our toolkit it
could be a number of different things it
could be a very focal approach like a
dry needling you know kind of centers on
trigger points and things like that and
dry needling for people who don't
recognize it number one I don't think
you can find practitioners in all states
I think yeah there's there's some
limitations significant amount of
lobbying that takes place around it but
dry needling is fair to say that same
tools of acupuncture but instead of
meridians I'd be very careful
as this entire conversation we're trying
so that would be a more Middle East of
yeah exercise physiology initiatives and
then certainly you know there are things
that are focal with respect to like
classic pen and stretch techniques and
things like that pin and stretch so this
is pinning something down pressing into
it yeah and then stretching it yeah and
then obviously the art fit into that art
is is certainly a focal approach right
an Active Release Technique absolutely
which is you know I had great success in
certain populations and then certainly
you have more diffuse approaches that
might cover a larger surface area
something like an instrument assisted
approach where they might scrape along
the entire length of your hamstrings
something like classic massage which
tends to cover a lot more square footage
and then and cupping could kind of go in
both directions you can cup and drag you
can throw a cup on one spot so there's a
lot of different ways that you can
impact the fascial system I'd say the
biggest misconception about it is that
it doesn't work I mean that's my
personal opinion I think there'll be
some folks from the paint science
community that will have really strong
disagreements my mindset has always been
if it's been on cave paintings for 5 000
years massage probably has its place and
we're just figuring out why it works I
don't think I'd be able to walk if I
didn't have regular soft tissue work
yeah you know it's a challenging thing
to study for sure I do think that the
academic world is doing a better job of
actually starting to learn more about
how different fascial layers glide on
one another we're actually starting to
get some of the technology that can kind
of see how things change pre and post
treatment at the end of the day we have
necessarily elucidated exactly why it
works and it's probably not even my
place to say but we are big bags of
water and probably what's happening with
fascial interventions is that we're
changing the way that fluids move so
that folks do have better gliding of
tissues that are adjacent to one another
I don't think we're mechanically
breaking down Scar Tissue maybe we're
stimulating the nervous system in a
unique way that transiently reduces the
risk of that threat and maybe creates
this short-term opportunity Unity for us
to put in the right exercise
interventions for motor learning and
that's the stuff that I think that's
missed some people might not have a good
experience of manual therapy either
because they work on the wrong places
they do the wrong approach or what I see
more commonly is they get that transient
reduction in symptoms and what they
don't do is followed up with the right
interventions to make the changes stick
so they feel good for 10 or 12 hours and
then the next day they go right back to
hurting but I can say for all of my
interactions with athletes you know the
success of a business manual therapy has
been a very important inclusion part of
the reason that I've traveled to where
we're recording today is to do multiple
sessions with someone who focuses on
facial manipulation and I won't name
names but I was introduced to this
person by a friend PhD in Neuroscience
who
thought she had effectively permanent
injury or disabilities related to
multiple childbirths and nothing even
reduce the symptoms and I recognize this
as an anecdote but she
was completely transformed after two or
three sessions and you know I try to
wear a skeptical but not cynical hat
also recognizing it's easy to throw the
baby out with the bathwater sometimes I
think you might agree like some of these
amazing soft tissue workers may be very
good at getting clinical outcomes but
they may not even themselves understand
the exact mechanisms by which they're
getting these outcomes but one thing
that I did notice
immediately was improved range of motion
in my ankles I've had a lot of lower leg
injuries and in the last two weeks after
getting them pulverized basically it's
incredible to notice on a daily basis
how much more range of motion I have and
I certainly need to strengthen into
those new ranges but I'm excited to see
where it goes and I'm sure we'll get
lots of strong opinions on the internet
where does it make sense to go next we
could talk about fascia we could talk
about
low back more if we wanted could you
talk to the role of the glutes
with respect to low back pain or lack
thereof yeah for sure and I think the
whole glute Amnesia thing maybe has been
a little overdone I tend to look at them
as part of a comprehensive system I mean
that we live in a population that's lost
a lot of hip extension the ability to
obviously get your upper leg behind your
body and we don't have adequate hip
extension we go somewhere else to
substitute for it so two big things
happen when that's the case you either
get too much motion through your
blowback so you get lumbar extension
instead of hip extension we tend to see
that particularly if you see like
fatiguing Runners you know as time goes
on they just kind of keep arching their
back more and more you also you know
have kind of the way that the joint
itself is controlled where your glutes
are really really important is they kind
of terminally extend your hip they give
you that last 10 degrees of hip
extension that are so important and what
happens is when they don't really do
their job at Terminal hip extension you
get a very hamstrings dominant pattern
and a lot of people because of the way
the hamstrings attach in your pelvis
will actually wind up with like an
irritation in the front of the hip so
sometimes you know if the glutes don't
do their job it's not just the back pain
aspect of things but it's also a
function of people kind of wind up
beating up on the front side of the
joint that could be that could be an
issue for me yeah I look at it very much
the glutes are kind of your rotator cuff
of your hip I think less about activate
the glutes activate the glutes and I
think more about how do we clean up our
hip extension patterns so that they're
actually taking place in the right place
but the glutes you know it's a buzzword
you know it's it's certainly something
that I think has gotten some good
momentum For Better or For Worse in kind
of the exercise Community but I look
much more at how does it fit into the
big picture particularly because we just
talked about fascial system it's
probably less about individual muscles
and more about how comprehensive
movements are controlled in a reasonably
tight window where does
and you get to find terms here but where
does this is the leading question
strengthening the posterior chain fit
into this posterior chain hamstring
glutes adductor Magnus and to some
degree the lower back like all these
things are vitally and stuff on the back
yeah everything on the back side of the
body I mean I think just in general we
know that we're stronger in hinging
patterns if we're looking at functional
carryover to the real world and our
ability to attack what life stress is I
think Peter did a great job in his
recent book just talking about the need
to be be strong into hip hinges do you
need to deadlift 800 pounds no but in
general these are high cross-sectional
area muscles that probably have a lot
more of an ability to to help us and
most people are going to be stronger in
a hinge pattern than they are in a squat
pattern so it's probably the most
biomechanically efficient way for most
people to accomplish various lifting
tasks whether it's something that's
significant in the gym or something
that's as simple as picking up a bag of
groceries or a kid what are your go-to
exercises if you can only pick two or
three let's just say four the
strengthening of the posterior chain and
that hinging action where would you go
without a failure looking at a deadlift
and deadlift is a broad categorization
you might have a trap bar deadlift or a
kettlebell deadlift something that in
those Realms are going to be a little
bit easier to teach a lot of people go
right to the straight bar and some
people just are not biomechanically set
up to be successful with that so we
don't necessarily go to that things like
kettlebell swings if you're ready for
the patterning and the higher velocity I
think a lot of people need to train
power as much as they need to train
strength particularly as we age and
that's a a low impact alternative to
going out and sprinting or jumping that
you know isn't going to leave an
Achilles on the floor so I I think
kettlebell swings probably have some
Merit in that discussion certainly
various hip thrust opportunities have
come about in the industry from you know
wide variety of exercise selections
there I think you know some people
probably do better with them than others
but I do think there's a place for it
anything in those worlds or good single
leg rdls as well it's kind of like a
Romanian deadlift yeah something
underneath that deadlift umbrella but
they're at the end of the day most of
them are going to be deadlift
derivatives same thing with a kettlebell
swings it's a deadlift that you just
execute quickly why is power
important as we age in addition to
strength and maybe you could
differentiate the two so really think of
power as your strength with a Time
component it's how quickly we can apply
force and you'll see powerlifting is
really not powerful it's slow movement
yeah
most of the athletes you see on TV are
really really powerful the guys that are
running fast and jumping high that's
kind of a in-person demonstration of
power but I think where power is tricky
we do know that it tends to de-train
fastest strength aerobic capacity they
actually stick around pretty well
assuming you're not like a crazy high
level of those things you can probably
train it if you're in an intermediate to
slightly Advanced stage you can probably
train it once every 30 days and it's
gonna power no I'm talking about
strength and aerobic capacity yeah on
the power side of things it seems like
they it starts to detrain in as little
as five to seven days so it's very
important to actually challenge it and
where it becomes vitally important as we
age is you know this is the stuff that
protects you when you're older and you
want to avoid Falls and we know that you
know you fracture your hip it's for a
lot of people it's honestly a death
sentence as terrible as it sounds
because you know it markedly impacts
your Mobility we know that the the
cognitive decline after you know a loss
of ambulation is is really substantial
so we see a lot of people that just tend
to spiral after Falls being honest my
own father passed away a couple years
ago after we fell down our several
seller steps and fractured as clavicle
and it was very interesting maybe in the
context of the orthopedic relationship
to systemic factors he kind of went
through multi-system failure he was
unhealthy but a clavicle fracture on a
fall really kind of like pushed him over
the edge on it would Training Power have
helped that probably not but I think for
a lot of people that you know wind up
with hip fractures and things like that
we have to be very mindful of how power
could potentially prevented it so first
I'm sorry to hear that I did and second
could you give an example of what type
of power training might be incorporated
to help mitigate the risk of a fall for
instance
it sounds terrible to say any kind of
sprinting you know I'm not saying go out
at age 80 and Sprint but we do see
people in those ages that play tennis
regularly that are involved in things
that are that are higher velocity that
involve changing direction so I think a
lot of it is remain athletic into age so
what do we do with folks we'll we'll
throw Med balls we'll do kind of and for
people who may not get that some
medicine balls weighted balls yeah
you're sort of throwing against a wall
or on the floor exactly and relatively
low risk for folks can be really helpful
but I think people sometimes Overlook
how much they do my grandmother is 99
years old and she still golfs that's her
version of power training and she's you
know she's got two new hips and one knee
and she's been doing great Robocop on
the golf course exactly so I think
that's vitally important if you don't
use it you lose it and it's a function
of a lot of things that's Mobility
that's strength the power is probably
the the most important of the bunch when
we talk about aging everyone's going to
get stiff as they age but you don't want
to be stiff and weak slash slow
so before we delve back into the weeds I
thought we would take just a little
breather and talk about books because of
the rapid fire questions that I had sent
over before we met up you had
highlighted a few that might be
unpacking so let's begin with what is
the book or what are the books that you
have gifted often before
I'm gonna give you two because they're
kind of categories to it I'd say the
first one underneath this Health and
Human Performance realm diagnosis and
treatment of movement impairment
syndromes it's a Shirley sarmon book
that I I think is Landmark it's I mean
it's decades old super impactful kind of
reads like stereo instructions so you're
going to go through a page at a time but
sermon is still practicing a physical
therapist at washu in St Louis you know
I think that one impacted me the most is
we had always had this very pathology
driven model of movement where it was
like all right you have biceps
tendonitis here is what we're going to
do to treat it we're going to do
ultrasound on the biceps and you're
going to do this this and this and it
changed the perspective from that
medical diagnosis to to a movement
diagnosis instead we started saying all
right you have scapular downward
rotation syndrome and someone that's in
this position from a movement standpoint
could have a Lads train they could have
biceps tendinopathy they could have a
rotator cuff irritation so it made us
realize that one movement issue could
create a number of different pathologies
versus going and you know having a
diagnosis of biceps tendonitis could
come from a collection of different
things so it got us thinking a lot
differently about that so that's one
that I've I've recommended and gifted
you know quite a bit over the years in a
different category chip and Dan Heath's
books across the board are excellent I
think the longer I'm in this industry
the more I realize that it's all about
closing the gap between what I know and
what I Implement I think so much of
their stuff is behavioral nature
understanding what makes people tick and
you know how to get them to buy into
different things I think Dan Heath's
latest book upstream was really really
good just in the concept of thinking
about what are the things that are
Upstream in terms of our athlete's
success well it's sleep it's nutrition
it's taking care of these higher level
Concepts before we even get into the
nuances of the particular exercise that
we're giving them and things like that
and to be honest Peter attia's latest
book which I just finished in the last
week is probably going to Trend in that
direction some of the stuff that's meant
for longevity still optimizes
performance for athletes you'd be
shocked at how many seemingly healthy 30
year old professional athletes have
absolutely horrific blood work that
really needs to be addressed and I think
that's something that could be a good
one too so actually just got that from
my mom so nice um three categories I
guess there yeah I got it for my dad as
well just a quick side note of trivia so
the heath Brothers was made to stick I
think it was forever ago
had the speaking session right before me
in
March of 2007
when I gave my very first presentation
ever about the then forthcoming
four-hour Work Week wow so they were
right before me I was a nobody and they
were the nicest guys they're great
they're just fantastic humans their
stuff reads awesome decisive is another
really good book I actually gifted that
to a number of different athletes who
have been drafted who have tried to
decide between signing and going to
college and just outlines the
decision-making process really well so
good stuff across the board will
probably return back to some of these
rap fire questions but now that we gave
everyone a Scooby Snack
let's go back to something you mentioned
earlier you did mention medical
diagnosis versus movement diagnosis and
feel free to get into this any way that
makes sense but could you expand on
movement diagnosis what you mean by that
for sure and that is in many ways a
derivative of sarman's work we just
talked about I'll speak to maybe my own
example I was a tennis player in high
school got recruited to play I was a as
many coaches are I was a fantastically
mediocre athlete I was I was all state
in the state of Maine problem is there's
only about a million people and not a
lot of people play tennis so you know
upside was probably division three
tennis but I dealt with a lot of
shoulder issues that ultimately kind of
limited me from going on and playing
college tennis and this started you know
my junior in high school and really it
was present all the way through my
college Years as I kind of walked away
from Tennessee I worked at a club in
strong rackets and gave lessons and
things like that but in reality it was
something that really plagued me for a
good five six years to the point that I
was in pretty significant pain actually
in the summer between my undergraduate
experience at my the start of grad
school I was diagnosed I had an under
surface cuffed hair which is a really
common diagnosis it's internal
impingement really something you see all
the I'm in a throwing population it's
basically a instead of in a classic like
general population rotator cuff
irritation you'll see tearing on the top
side so the bursal side I had an
articular sided tear so they understand
from serving that's exactly what it is
it's that big externally rotated
abducted serve you see it in baseball
players swimmers tennis players and I
went through physical therapy and I
didn't get better I'd gone through
multiple courses of it and so I went off
to grad school in the fall of 2003
thinking I was going to have surgery
over winter break I was gonna you know
suck it up for a few months I was gonna
have surgery the day I got back from
break you know being a sling for a
couple weeks and then hopefully go back
and do the spring semester was it a
complete tear partial tear it was a
partial tear which to be honest if you
look at the research sometimes they're
the most stubborn because they're most
painful yeah a lot of people you know
I've seen Achilles or patellar ruptures
where people have no pain once they
finally rupture it's when they've got
like a partial tear that's more painful
it might be not very highly functional
but so I went off to college or to grad
school in the fall of 2003 expecting to
have surgery in three months and decided
you know what I'm gonna just try to
figure I'm going to be a guinea pig in
the I guess in the tier Tim Ferriss way
I'm going to experiment so I completely
redesigned my training program took out
a lot of stuff added some new stuff and
and just significantly I found actually
a good art guy down the street how did
you make those decisions
I had nothing left to lose and a lot of
it was just self-education reading what
was out there and again this is 2003 so
the internet now it wasn't as easy back
then to kind of dig deep so it was a lot
more asking questions and sure enough
gotta go to good art down the street and
first time I had somebody dig a thumb in
my subscapularis like oh that feels good
pretty much changed my life yeah bruised
armpits and all that stuff but
um I remember I'll never forget
Halloween Day 2003 I I called my my
surgeon's office and I canceled the
surgeon I was completely asymptomatic
now how would you weight the factors
that led to that was the art
subscap release a revelation were there
other things I think it was a lot of it
as I look back I wanted to know what
were the shortcomings that defined my
experience in physical therapy why
didn't I get better how could I have
re-engineered it differently I think the
first thing I'll say is like it was a
classic kind of insurance driven
Physical Therapy model I was one of six
patients at a time some of them were
grandmother rotator cuff repairs some of
them may be gymnast with stress
fractures I was a 22 year old athletic
guy who had shoulder pain and needed to
learn and so there was probably an
element of like the exercises just not
being done correctly with not enough
eyes on me so I think that was the first
one second as I applied I really had no
manual therapy it was not a hands-on
experience for me that was particularly
important I had a pretty significant
athletic background and I'm sure I'd
been accumulating a lot of gunk in my
armpit as I implied and they didn't
touch my neck and just in reality it was
it could have been re-engineered
markedly different but I think the
biggest thing for me is there was no
counseling about what else I was doing
that wasn't necessarily with respect to
sleep or hydration it sort of intake the
incompleteness of the intake right the
variables were not controlled enough I
might have come in and done all the
exercises great and it didn't matter
because the training that I was doing on
my own maybe my activity patterns in
both work and in training were just not
ideal so it made me realize that when we
actually wanted to eventually design
this system acrossy Sports Performance
like one of the things that we needed to
do was build out a team where everybody
was rolling in the right direction that
there was no stone that was left
unturned and that when I see people who
have failed rehab like I do often it's
one of those things they didn't have
anybody put their hands on them or
they've been giving other exercises they
thought would be helpful and they've
been doing them completely incorrectly
so I kind of have my checklist that I go
through I have certain exercises that
are in almost every rotator cuff paying
patience programs and we come and we
look at them and 75 of the time they're
just not being done correctly even
because they weren't taught or they
weren't being supervised and it's to
some degree maybe it's a flawed business
model it's maybe some of the challenges
with insurance driven Physical Therapy
but it's not really rehab unless you're
doing the exercise correctly so I hate
it when people say I failed rehab it's
like no sometimes rehab failed you you
were trying and you just didn't get the
right coaching queue or the right
intervention that you needed totally and
I should say and this might seem obvious
to everyone but
the worst case is not that you don't get
better you can also get worse and I
think about a partial labrum Terror that
you know among my dozens of other
injuries I had about
two years ago from getting back into
snowboarding and just getting hyper
aggressive immediately because I'm an
idiot and uh long story short it was
misdiagnosed and then I was given
exercises that had a really strong kind
of PNF
internal rotation aspect and it just
made it so much worse for weeks until I
was able to say wait a second we see
that a lot in the Baseball World in
baseball players if you think about what
external rotation is imagine what a
baseball pitcher has to do to throw like
insane to really lay their own back they
have freakish extra rotation but we
actually see in the throwing shoulders
something called retroversion and it's
not actually an adaptation that takes
place when kids are playing catch in the
backyard at age eight nine and they
actually warp their growth plates and
they acquire more shoulder layback and
it's advantageous it helps you to throw
hard and actually probably spares the
elbow a little bit but what we see is
they actually present with less internal
rotation on their throwing shoulder than
they do on their non-throwing shoulder
and so it's in normal asymmetry and what
we'll sometimes see in clinicians that
don't see a lot of baseball pitchers
they all of a sudden get their eyes and
it's like oh my gosh we got to stretch
them into intern rotation because
they're you know asymmetrical and you
will actually see scenarios where the
rehabilitation has created other
challenges whether it's a yes to your
capsule tear or irritation under cuff so
what it really speaks to for me is that
rehab in general is getting more and
more nuanced and niched for lack of a
better term and and we started dealing
with this baseball population we quickly
realized that it was a very underserved
population it was either hey here's the
football program or here's the rehab
program don't lift heavy or just do the
football program and we realized that
you could push guys pretty hard if you
understood their unique demands and the
way that the game challenged them and
what subtle intricacies that you may
need to be put in from a exercise
selection coaching standpoint but we
also saw that the game was changing
dramatically
way more specialization with younger
kids playing baseball year round the
massive increase in fastball velocity
that's still taking place the average
Major League player you know gained 22
pounds 12 percent increase from 188
Pounds to 210 pounds from 1990 to 2010.
the game has just played at these
insanely high speeds so if you have like
a generic program and you have maybe
doctors that don't see a lot of baseball
players and all those things that you're
not going to be very well conditioned
for it yeah yeah man Sports evolved
quickly you know you look at MMA or you
look at tennis we were talking about
this before we got started recording
just the average heights it's incredible
men you don't see many Michael Changs
playing professional tennis anymore he
was the freaky athletic but these guys
are monsters nowadays they're much much
bigger hit the ball down at you yeah
average basketball velocity in the major
leagues climbs every single year and if
you look like my experience we founded
our facility in 2007 if you were a
left-handed pitcher who was throwing 91
to 92 miles an hour you're a first round
pick nowadays you see guys consistently
throwing 100 miles an hour some of those
kids can't even get drafted it's
incredible how much it's changed that's
incredible so let's tie your personal
experience
with your own issues when you're younger
say 22 your personalization of your own
program having these breakthroughs with
say the Hands-On with with art which is
is really remarkable a whole lot of
levels I encourage people to check it
out myofascial release more broadly
speaking also and if you have a kink for
BDSM we're not sure where to find a
convenient dungeon let's say you can get
the subscap manipulation to get your fix
because it [__] hurts yes very
unpleasant you can get some like iliacus
if you really want to double down or uh
so has work while you're at it let's tie
your personal story back into the
broader question of movement diagnosis I
think the challenge then becomes I look
back and I can see how I moved poorly
that's the challenge to me is that I was
treated as a rotator cuff patient when I
should have been treated as here are the
things there I didn't postarily tell my
scapula well I didn't upwardly rotate
well I had poor end range rotator cuff
control so I think I would speaks to is
that if we're talking about medical
advocacy being the overarching theme of
our discussion meaning enabling people
to navigate things effectively yeah and
I think when the conversation was
initially happening it was talking about
hey our parents are aging how do you
advocate for your parents when they're
getting Medical Care and you're having
to make a lot of these hard I guess
conversations take place but I think
there is a need for it on the orthopedic
side of things how do you advocate for
yourself as a patient when your
shoulders barking at you and I I think
for me I I always come back to like you
have to do a lot of questioning you have
to ask to make sure like how specialized
is my issue in the baseball world we had
a teenage athlete this is 2008 or so
right after we opened up and we had
significant medial elbow symptoms pain
on the inside of his elbow with throwing
and super stubborn had been to a doctor
MRI was clean clean in quotes always
which I never really loved as a term but
kept having issues and he was just he
went to a general Ortho and long story
short he found his way orthopedic
surgeon yeah long story short found his
way to an elbow specialist which is not
a super common specialty and more
importantly was an orthopedic help
especially who had an affiliation with a
major league baseball team so he's used
to seeing these all the time and he
quickly diagnosed him with a subluxating
ulnar nerve some percentage of the
population has him on a nerve that kind
of goes back and forth over the medial
epicondyle so your funny bone kind of
moves depending on position and the
challenge is when you throw a baseball
and you go from flexion to extension
it'll flare that nerve up so you're
really predisposed to nerve irritation
plucking a face basic guitar string the
kid lost a year and a half and it wound
up being an ulnar nerve transposition it
was a pretty quick surgery and he he
came back played college baseball but
looking back on that I was like I never
wanted to not be an advocate for an
athlete because I didn't know so for me
that was really important is we needed
to be very very specialized in our
particular realm which you know was
baseball and it eventually morphed into
shoulders elbows neck for all overhead
athletes we see you know tennis players
swimmers and sure enough probably six or
12 months after that we had another
baseball player who came in and I had
really kind of immersed myself in in all
the research and things like that Adam
kid came in with a really mundane
shoulder Radiology report he had an MRI
he had a little bit of posterior labral
fraying which is literally a hundred
percent of major league baseball players
they all have fraying and they're
posterior shoulder like I looked at this
kid's MRI and like if I was a major
league team I'd give you 150 million
without a problem with this MRI and
there was a doctor that wanted to do
surgery on it just because he had some
symptoms I was like let's pump the
brakes let's actually rehab this but
they treated the MRI instead of the kid
in front of him he literally did like
four weeks of PT did a good return to
throwing program he went on he played
four years of college baseball and never
had shoulder issues again so I look back
on that and that year was very
transformative that I needed to be an
advocate for my athletes because they
didn't know much like I didn't know when
I was younger and really the quest over
the last you know 15 years has been how
do we continue to build out our team at
our facility but also the network of
people to whom we can refer just because
as the game is getting more specialized
we need to be more specialized and who
cares for our people in the service of
helping people to advocate for
themselves
the intent being of course in this
conversation not to say do what I do
because I have an unusual Network right
I can call you I can call Kelly Starrett
I can call yeah various Specialists you
brought up questions and asking
questions are there any particular
questions and you could pick a condition
like it could be a shoulder but it could
be a lower back something Orthopedic or
potentially Orthopedic what are some of
the tools or questions
you might recommend to folks who are
hoping to become better advocates for
themselves first and yeah maybe we talk
about parents later
first and foremost it's asking around
who's had favorable experiences with
different Physicians obviously bedside
Manor plays into this tremendously you
want to make sure that you're dealing
with a surgeon who is accessible if
things don't go well things like that so
you know we try to really align
ourselves with people who have great
bedside manner we've been really
fortunate to have some really strong
relationships in that realm so I think
that's important how do you find those
doctors if you're not a yeah it's it's
obviously it's conversations and I'm not
sure that reading patient reviews online
is great because you always tend to get
just the really bad ones are the people
that take the time to write it up but I
think asking people in your network who
have been to these folks particularly if
there's a geographic component hey I I
live in Oklahoma and I need to see
someone who's within 30 minutes of me so
that's the first thing the second thing
I would I would say is how specialized
is it it's one thing if you break your
leg that happens all the time people are
pretty well equipped to handle that when
you have this very odd collection of
symptoms something that's unique things
like a thoracic outlet syndrome is a
more specialized thing basically your
thoracic outlet is you know based where
all the nerves and blood vessels have
your operations start up at your neck
and it can be effectively clamped off at
multiple different points so it can
become a hard diagnosis when you see
numbness and tingling in the fingers and
you don't know whether it's the neck at
the shoulder at the elbow all these
different things so that's a harder
diagnosis that's much more specialized
so I think you have to be aware of the
more complex it is the more you might
need to travel the one thing I actually
talk about the most is when we're
talking about Rehabilitation Specialists
I think it's always important to make
sure you do some digging on what's the
model that's employed in this
Rehabilitation realm is it a lot of
one-on-one Hands-On is it one person
supervising eight patients at the same
time is there a manual therapy component
to it do you have experience working in
these specific post-operative cases or
with this something like an Achilles
rupture is a pretty specialized injury
just someone who's done shoulder rehab
all the time isn't necessarily going to
be able to handle someone who's had a
post-op Achilles so you have to be
mindful of how specialized the actual
Rehabilitation may be I think that's big
and then kind of building out that you
can always just scrutinize a resume I
think that goes a long way I always
worry when it's like Bob Smith is a
chiropractor that does this he likes
long walks on the beach has a wife and
two dogs yeah and and you read their bio
and like there's no substance when I
read a bio for someone I can refer to
what I think I messed with that guy a
hinge I'm just kidding what I always
want is I wanna I want someone who's got
like a number of different skill sets in
their toolbox because if you're a
carpenter who only has a hammer
everything starts looking like a nail
yeah so you're looking for some people
that can delve into different
methodologies to try to help get you
better
yeah totally tell me if this is a decent
heuristic to use my bias has always been
to work with practitioners I'm using
that deliberately pretty broadly
whether they're soft tissue
folks or surgeons or
otherwise who work with a lot of
currently competitive athletes just
because
please feel free to rip this apart but
my feeling is with sedentary folks there
may not be a clear pass fail so it's
harder to get an accurate read of
whether the surgery delivered
would have intended to deliver in terms
of outcomes but with athletes if they
are say an Iron Man triathlete and
they're having trouble running because
of X with their right leg and the
promise is we will fix your right leg so
you can get back to running that is
very simple too in a sense figure out
from a past fail perspective like are
they able to run and compete or not and
I just like maybe the Simplicity of that
any thoughts on that the Simplicity in
identifying those people yes the
complexity of what it takes it probably
makes it a useful approach is a key
consideration so I would say is there's
there's being asymptomatic there's a
return to play and then there's return
to Performance those are three very
different things like a surgeon can make
you asymptomatic and you can lose all of
your range of motion and not be able to
return to play if you're a recreational
tennis player and you can't get your arm
up you're not going to be able to serve
and then it's another thing altogether
you get back to return to Performance
and I think when you deal with
clinicians who are used to dealing with
those higher level athletes that's their
outcome measure is return to Performance
when you talk to Major League Baseball
doctors it's can you come back and pitch
in the big leagues and throw 98 miles an
hour anymore or not and you know it's
not just the surgeon it's not just the
physical therapist it's the entire team
because you can you can do a lot of
things wrong along the way so I do think
the standard of care is probably higher
when you're dealing with those
competitive athletes there's also just a
mindfulness to timelines is that hey we
can't just mess around we want to be
proactive with the so I think it's
useful I would never pull the rug out
for any people that haven't worked in
that population you know if they've
proven themselves clinically and you
know they really care because there's
absolutely a need for that but yeah it
probably gives you a little bit more
mindfulness to how people look at the
injury too treating them like an athlete
not just like a patient I think that's
probably important
yeah I found that
if you're in any decent sized city or
close to a decent sized city you don't
have to find someone from the Yankees if
you can give you referral to their
favorite Ortho the chances are there's
some sports team that outperforms
relative to other sports team it could
be high school it could be a college
team
and it would be relatively trivial to
reach out to say a coach and be like
when your players have problems with X
where do you go do you have anyone you
that you like to send people to yeah and
at least I've found that too
maybe I'm biased I probably am biased
just as a former athlete but I
I really have found that beneficial and
not maybe as intimidating or as
difficult as people might think which is
not to totally minimize folks who don't
specialize in athletes but it's a pretty
straightforward shorthand what else
should we talk about relative to
movement diagnosis and one thing that
came to mind for me which I'll just
throw out there in case it takes us
somewhere is there's a difference
between
understanding the structure or
structural abnormalities and then the
function and like the patterning that
someone uses coming back to that book
recommendation yeah but what else can
you say about movement diagnosis and how
perhaps people listening can think about
more of that yeah
um so the first thing I would say is is
that you know movement diagnosis doesn't
necessarily just need to be under the I
guess original algorithms that sermon
outlined in that book which I think are
excellent we still utilize day-to-day
but I think what it does is it gives
rise to this thought process of there's
so many other things that go into it
I'll give you an example we often see in
an athletic population like a scapular
depression their shoulder blades sit
very low like as we're talking about
this like you have downslope shoulders
it's really something we see a lot in
people have deadlifted Olympic lifted
thrown a baseball done anything
imaginable in an extension of rotation
sport athlete particularly if they've
combined it with a lot of strength
conditioning so sometimes we see you
know shoulder pain in that population
because they just get stuck so far are
down in scapular depression their
shoulder blades sit so low that they
they can't possibly get their arms
overhead safely so we teach them better
patterning we adjust their exercise
selection to drive more movement of the
shoulder blades to get their arms
overhead we do overhead carries and we
teach them what better movements are we
you know we do soft tissue work on the
lats all these different things that
allow them to move better but if that
same person goes and just does a bunch
of Farmer's walk at the end of this
session it can become a problem can you
say a little bit more about soccer
farmers walk just taking heavy heavy
weights right so basically not undoing
the good work that you've done but yeah
doing something that something that
reinforces exactly that just brings us
right back to it and that's something I
think that happens a lot and certainly
there are times when that's
non-modifiable in the context of hey I
play football for a living and I have a
concussion I still need to run into
people some things like that are very
very challenging we're talking about the
training initiatives that a lot of
people either use to support their
athletic participation or what people
use for their Fitness initiatives those
are very modifiable so I think we need
to be mindful of always being willing to
adjust the program in the Avenue so we
have some athletes honestly that have
that predisposition that I just talked
about and they don't deadlift they know
farmers walk they don't do walking
lunges we do a lot of stuff in the front
squat position maybe we use a safety
squat bar on their back we can find
different ways to load them that won't
interfere with our ability to create
optimal movement so often it's not just
about what you do it's about what you
decide not to do and that's often the
hardest part is sometimes you have to
counsel athletes away from something
that they might really enjoy are there
any particular exercises that you think
are
remarkably
overestimated
over popular like if you could just wave
a magic wand and remove a handful of
exercises anything make that list I
really I've always hesitated to
contraindicate exercises I think I tend
to contraindicate people for exercise as
more often we never rule it out I do
think there's kind of an interesting
Trend now of a lot of people who are
well into middle age who have lost in
movement capacity they've gotten into a
lot of like Olympic lifting and
gymnastics training and we forget that
most really high level gymnasts do that
from a young age they they built their
business and they hold on to it over an
extended period of time they don't pick
it up after they've already had like one
rotator cuff repair and spent 25 years
at a desk so I do think that's an area
where we need to be really really
cognizant of well let's use a case
that's right in front of us so got this
weird lower back thing yeah
any exercises you'd be like yeah maybe
for the next
period of time yeah I mean I strike
these from the record yeah I think you
know for the most part if you're looking
at some of the blanket statements
particularly based on some of the things
you've told me and I haven't looked at
you yet but it doesn't sound like heavy
bilateral loading is your best friend it
seem like uh you know something like
initiative that's not my best yeah
compression in kind of positions that
don't allow you to bail out very well
that you know kind of two-legged stuff
is probably not your best friend and
some people just don't do well with it I
think we see kind of your classic flat
spines they generally tend to be people
that are more susceptible to discogenic
issues and they they don't handle
compression really well so when I see a
plumber spine I'm probably not thinking
it's going to be an 800 pound deadlifter
coming in
so when you examine me later this will
be shortly after we wrap recording
what type of movement diagnoses what are
some examples of movement you moved me
through so like I said we'll start with
some static posture stuff and I would
get a look at just standing looking yeah
and that stuff just stare at you and
judge you yeah um but then actually
we'll do some table based assessments
and not just because table based meaning
I lay down correct so I look at hip and
internal and external rotation
collection different things like that
and one of the things you want to look
at for something like that is you might
have a wildly stiff hip that just
doesn't move and your spine's paying the
price so we kind of look at some of that
and then actually from a functional
standpoint probably look at a toe touch
pattern assuming it's not too
problematic look at some squat patterns
as well I'm big on measuring
infrastructural angle um infrastinal
angle
um yeah a lot to unpack there that's a
lengthy podcast but what is that just
just think of the angle at the bottom of
your rib cage you have some people that
are very wide and some people that are
very narrow when you have a wide
infrastrinal angle they tend to be very
kind of hingy in their squats they're
built for toe touches versus a narrow
and firsternal angle will usually be a
very very good squat pattern they may
struggle to hinge and it kind of creates
this little like I put it underneath the
postural I guess measures but it gives
us a little bit of a glimpse into how
people may move so there's a there's an
emerging school of thought that I think
is really profound in that regard so the
what was the term again infrastinal
angle so a large infrastinal angle could
I translate that to wide rib cage or is
that not quite wide versus narrow yeah
so yeah okay and credit to Bill Hartman
bill has done some wonderful stuff in
terms of being this to the Forefront I
think I have a large
external I would say generally speaking
people who are biased towards being
really really strong like weight lifters
power lifters NFL linebackers running
backs they're often your wide folks I
think when you look a lot more at like
some of your really like your high
jumpers some of your six foot 360 pound
pitchers who throw 95 miles an hour they
generally tend to be narrow there's just
different ways to get jobs done and
sometimes people we'll uh we'll get into
bad patterns just because they get a
little bit too adhered to the the things
that come naturally good to them so
let's just say if since people may be
familiar with this movement in the case
of a squat so you'll have me
perform a few different variations of
the squat what will that look like and
then what will you be looking for we'll
look at a little test retest on it so I
usually will do an overhead squat um
it's kind of like a gateway to it
holding my arms overhead yeah correct so
generally try to keep you in a non kind
of compensated position in other words
like won't let you turn your toes way
out and go to an ultra wide stance so we
just want to see what unpacks and what's
great you kind of I joke if you look for
everything you see nothing so we can see
everything from shoulder Mobility to
upper back Mobility to how well you
hinge through your hips to whether you
have adequate dorsiflexion really
through your ankles and also just how
you position your center of mass we can
also look you know do you shift to one
side or the other you mentioned a you
know a leg length asymmetry you you know
we talked about potentially there being
like a bony block and a hip all those
things are stuff that we need to kind of
keep in mind so and then we'll do some
modifiers right if it doesn't look good
then we're probably going to go and
we're going to try some like a
counterbalance where you don't have your
hands up overhead see if the pattern
improves then we'll just kind of like
Workshop it in the sense that you know
you screen out it was was it terrible
because the ankles didn't move did you
fall over just because you can't
reposition your center of mass
effectively all those things are on the
table yeah you're mentioning the 45 year
olds like me getting into gymnastics
strength training which I actually I'm a
huge fan of but if you talk to the
people who really know what they're
doing like coach Chris summer he
Advocates people taking their time yes
with the connective tissue remodeling
yeah
uh I think humans and maybe especially
Americans are pretty bad at heating that
but you you see also and you mentioned
this same thing in some say later in
life
Olympic lifters who begin they just
don't have that dorsiflexion right the
flexibility in the ankles which a lot of
these competitors have developed from a
pretty young age and then they have all
these compensations above the ankles
that create just Mayhem yeah
biomechanically I never have loved the
term injury prone I would say there's
injury predisposed and I think they're
very different things like injury
predispobes is the guy that rolled his
ankle in high school and didn't do
anything about it yeah all of a sudden
he's got you know way more dorsiflexion
on one side and the other and he just
kind of becomes this helicopter pattern
of movement where everything is kind of
rotating in the wrong places so I think
those are the things that we need to be
really mindful of and if you're a 50
year old man getting into Olympic
lifting you're more predisposed to
injury than someone who's 15. it's not
to say it can't be done you know you
never want to discourage people from
their goals it's just the Beyond
boarding has to be a little bit
different yeah it is incredible to see
what some of these young athletes are
doing and maybe it's just more visible
to me I don't Olympic lift these days
but I subscribe to one account on
Instagram hook grip and they have these
competition shots you just see these
I mean in my mind kids they're like 18
19 just clean and jerking 480 490 pounds
it's it's wild I think in general we're
in an interesting transitional time for
young athletes I think a lot of this
conversation centered around like
self-medical act we see people on here
who are you know listening because
they're hip hurts or something like that
but like advocacy for your kids is a
really big thing is the the model is
changing dramatically like when I grew
up we played multiple Sports we played a
wide variety of sports until my mom you
know yelled out to come in for dinner
and now we have kids that are
legitimately playing baseball year round
playing soccer around and they're not
getting that broad Foundation that rich
proprioceptive environment and I think
orthopedically I know for a fact we're
paying the price for it in the baseball
Community because it's the most
specialized game it's the highest
velocity movement and the shoulder
internally rotates at 7 000 degrees per
second
um but we're also going to pay the price
when these guys are 35 years old and
getting shoulder Replacements and things
like that it just it just seems like in
general youth sports are really headed
in a negative Direction that's why what
I do I I in my eyes I feel is so
important you have a lot of career
stability
maybe not as good as the hip surgeons
but maybe yeah oh God yeah or the
dialysis manufacturer
maybe this will go nowhere but I'll
bring it up I've read that you're a fan
of the expression get long get strong
train hard and that's a good one fair to
say yeah it's a great it's a Charlie
weingrath line okay what does this mean
so get long right is create a transient
or more permanent change to range of
motion maybe that's some positional
breathing that gets you 15 degrees of
hip and turn rotation maybe it's some
soft tissue work that gets you some
shoulder flexion there's all these
different things and I'll backtrack to
that in a second but get long get strong
go ahead and do some exercises that make
that change stick so all right we're
gonna do a thoracic spine Mobility drill
to get some length and I'm gonna do a
kettlebell arm bar just to help kind of
hold it under load and then train hard
now I'm going to do quite a bit of
volume with ample load to make my brain
my body perceive it as normal so that I
hold those patterns like that's what
good training really does now here's the
problem we can all agree on what a good
lunge is and what's probably an
excessive amount of exercise so they get
strong and train hard everybody's
probably 99 percent in the same bucket
on it's the get long part people love to
argue about whether one discipline is
better than the other let's argue about
whether manual therapy works
even an argument that's incredible they
argue about whether positional breathing
is lame and boring and I think people
just like to fight on the internet yeah
but that's the challenge is we get so
caught up as an industry arguing about
the minutia of how to create a transient
change in range of motion that we've
said in the back of the week we agree on
the other two factors 99 of the time so
how frequently let's just say for
yourself right because you clearly still
train what does get long look like for
you as an example for me it's
historically been make the most of my
warm-ups if I take care of those whether
it's some self myofascial release like
get on a foam roll or doing some of that
stuff and for me it's much more targeted
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on
an area that I don't think needs it but
I'll I'll use an accumobility ball on my
neck a little bit just because my neck
gets a little gumped up and then I'll
follow it up with a more thorough
warm-up which is usually one to two
positional breathing exercise then I'd
say seven or eight exercises that are
more long chain compound movements what
do you mean by long chain yeah so things
that involve multiple joints so if you
do like a Spider-Man with hip lift and
overhead reach something like that as
some people call it world's greatest
like those are things that get you a
wide variety of movements across
multiple planes of motion those are
great and then after that I'm honestly
I'm doing something that's reasonably
powerful maybe it's throw some Med balls
or do a set of kettlebell swings that's
in the warm-up or after that kind of
like an extended warm-up is the way I
look at it maybe you sprint maybe you
jump something along those lines I just
think it's a good way to kind of like
get your body temperature up and
solidify some of that stuff and then
then we're gonna go I'm gonna lift and I
generally have four days a week and I'll
condition a couple days a week as well
how long does your warm-up take
um I would say it depends full
disclosure like I'd probably be a lot
better off if I follow my own advice
better but I'd say it's bare minimum 10
to 12 minutes I think the older I've
gotten The more I've realized that that
needs to be extended and I probably do
better when there are Target targeted
Mobility initiatives between sessions as
well I don't think anybody at 40 has
ever regretted doing more Mobility
exercises in their their 20s and 30s so
that would be my advice is even if you
don't think you need it you need it yeah
I'm chatting with Kelly about this and
maybe it was a profile piece that I read
where he was working with some NFL team
and he was talking to the guys and you
know the guys in there let's just say
earlier mid 20s we're kind of like
listening to music daydreaming not
paying attention he's talking about
warm-ups and so on and every single
player who's a veteran who's been there
for a while is paying complete attention
it's incredible I I never recognized it
honestly it was very impact for me I had
my my first orthopedic surgery I had a
meniscus repair I'd kind of ignored some
posterior medial knee pain in my uh my
left knee for a long time and I actually
finished it off Believe It or Not
Christmas Eve 2020. I was re-racking
away I went to Pivot and I caught it
just right heard a pop and ugh didn't
think anything of it kind of finished my
lift in the next you know hour later I
could barely move it but what was
fascinating about it to me was that I
had the surgery a couple weeks later and
two weeks non-weight bearing two weeks
partial weight-bearing and what blew my
mind was how quickly I lost motion and I
was taking care of the knee motion but
my inability to kind of move side to
side my adductor so growing tightness
was more significant you just noticed I
lost some shoulder Mobility during my
time on crutches it was just very
eye-opening that you know for me at the
time I was 39 it was not a uh you know
something that geriatric procedure I
should not have deteriorated that
quickly I don't feel like I mean I kept
my fitness up and I was able to work out
I was hopping around on one leg and
doing what I could but it was it was
extremely eye-opening to me that that
motion can be lost that quickly even if
you're paying attention to the
particular joint where you had surgery
and being very mindful of that so I
always try to counsel people on like the
downstream effects of some of those
Orthopedic interventions they're not
just necessarily fixing a shoulder or an
elbow in many cases your neck might get
Cranky from wearing that sling so just
be mindful of all the different places
where you could lose ocean like if
you're in a sling for four to six weeks
there's not a whole lot of arm swing
happening during your gait cycle so yeah
you could have some other impacts well I
remember getting my shoulder
reconstructed
this fantastic surgeon in SoCal
is recommended by I think he was
recommended by Scott Mendelson actually
famous power lifter benches thousand
something pounds literally yeah
literally it's not just an embellishment
and I remember paying so much attention
to the rehab being really meticulous on
the left arm but not really feeling like
I had marching instructions in
retrospect for the other arm I was
compensating of course using my right
arm in this case that was had not been
using my right arm in this case that I
did not received surgery for everything
and I ended up developing all of these
issues with the right shoulder yep and
the other thing too is even during your
rehab the crossover effect there's
there's research that shows that all
right let's say you have left shoulder
surgery you're in a sling assuming we do
it without obviously sending you back
there are things that we can do for your
right side they won't do anything to
minimize the Azure fee that might take
place on a shoulder side but from a pure
neurological standpoint we can do some
stuff to preserve the strength aspect of
it too so we always train the
non-injured side in our post-surgery
athletes I train my right leg a ton
while my left leg was on the men and the
crossover effect is a real thing
so I'm gonna drag us into the some deep
water let's do it and feel free to
interject or deflect or take us
somewhere else but I'm just going to
read a few things and then you can
modify
so this is in the context of I think it
was an interview on nickgrantham.com wow
yeah from some time ago but the
discussion was around creating
bulletproof athletes and I think that
was the wording from Nick so we have 10
points related to what would make or
could help make a bulletproof athlete
and I know this is a throwback so I'll
hand this over to you but let me just
read these first if that's okay with you
let's do it and then you can update
modify as needed so number one adequate
hip mobility we've spoken about this a
bit number two stability of the lumbar
spine scapulae and glenohumeral joint
number three posterior chain strength
and normal firing patterns let me speak
a little bit about that four loads of
posterior chain strength five more
pulling than pushing so more deadlift
rows pull-ups Etc than pushing squats
benches overhead pressing six greater
attention to single leg movements seven
prioritization of soft tissue work in
the form of foam rolling art and massage
eight attitude and then in parentheses
being afraid when you're under a bar as
a recipe for injury nine adequate
deloading periods 10 attention to daily
posture you have one to two hours per
day to train and 22 to 23 to screw it up
in your daily life so that's what we
have
is there anything that you would modify
here add to this maybe change because
you've adapted your thinking since this
was put on the internet I think the
first thing I would say is some of that
stuff is really just a plan on some of
the joint by join approach that a great
cook and might boil to their credit kind
of put out there is that you have
certain joints that are more conditioned
for Mobility things like the shoulder
right obviously have a lot of motion we
need to drive more motor control we use
the term stability I'm not sure it's a
great way to describe it and we have
other joints that obviously are you know
more built on hey they need to be really
really sturdy like a knee right it's a
hinge it's load-bearing all that stuff
so a lot of this is just hey preserve
what they're meant to do either be
mobile or be be more stable so I think I
would definitely adhere to all those
different things I think the part of the
stuff I might backtrack a little bit
from is the more pulling than pushing I
think for you know your general
population folks people who sit too much
that's still probably the case I think
in our athletic populations I've gotten
away from thinking of it just pushing
and thinking it more now is reaching
things to drive more rotational capacity
and some of that stuff but I think on
the other stuff there's some good
reminders in there the attitude aspect
of it where I commented being afraid
when you're under a bar as a recipe for
injury I actually see this a lot you
know you see it the most in the weight
room is people who don't take their warm
up seriously I can't tell you how many
times or people that just like jump
right to 225 on the bar and stuff like
that you always take the bar you always
take your first 45. if you look at most
powerful thing gems it's always plate
quarter plate quarter 45-25 all the way
up so can you explain that just for
people who may not have a view into this
so if we're talking about that would
apply to deadlifting as well yeah for
sure okay so yeah you've trained in some
facilities where people are pulling what
from the floor what would you say a
thousand yeah so pulling incredible
weight from the floor I mean not not
routinely but yeah 700 800 regularly yes
so what might there warm-up sequence
look yeah we don't have to go through
all of them I think at that level you're
gonna see guys for me personally if I'm
in a deadlift 600 it's going to be
usually 135 225 315 and once I've hit
315 I'm gonna go 25s all the way along
so it'd be 315 365 405 455 495. there's
a pretty significant build up to it you
don't just go and throw it on there and
it's usually your first exercise of the
day so there's an extra need for it but
you see so many people that just don't
know how to kind of flip the switch and
tap into the level of stiffness it takes
to move that kind of weight it's no
different than having like a major
league baseball pitcher go out and throw
their first ball at 95 miles or it's
like you know the first couple throws
are really really gradual and you build
up your long toss so I see a lot of
people that just don't have the right
mindset to really be handling heavy
weights and it's probably even worse
than when I actually probably gave this
interview just because there's more
distractions I mean this might have been
like 2010
um and here we are now people are
checking Instagram between us sets and
things like that so there's probably
even more of a recipe for people just
getting hurt because they aren't locked
in yeah well let's hop back into the
Scooby Snack category all right for a
moment what is the worst advice or
terrible advice that you hear or see
being given out often in your world just
bad advice I'm gonna throw one out there
that might be a little controversial is
um Follow Your Passion actually I've
never loved that advice in our field or
really really any field you know if you
if you look back like when I was dealing
with all these shoulder issues as an
athlete I was passionate about fantasy
sports and you know stuff like that
there was no livelihood to be made at
that time so I think what I did really
well early in my career was without even
knowing it some career Capital to steal
a cal Newport term what do you mean by
that just marketable skills you know
skills that would eventually serve me
without even knowing when I was going
through shoulder rehab and and all this
shoulder stuff like I was actually
working much more with basketball and
soccer athletes during my grad degree at
the University of Connecticut it just so
happened that some of the first athletes
I worked with in the private sector were
baseball players and because I had had
all these shoulder issues and dealt with
them myself I think I identified a
really underserved population even more
than I otherwise would have would that
have been the case if I had spent my
entire undergraduate year boozing and
not do anything like I didn't do that
instead I I worked I experimented I was
in the gym every single day and I was
annoying people that I knew were a lot
smarter than me so I never loved the
idea of people following their passion I
think you you follow your marketable
skills and eventually as Newport the
book was be so good they can't ignore
you he talked a lot about being able to
redeem those eventually for other things
maybe it's more compensation maybe it's
a better work-life balance more autonomy
whatever it may be too often in our
industry everybody has these very
similar resumes everyone has an exercise
science degree everybody has a letter
recommendation from their academic
supervisor and their high school
volleyball coach or whatever it is and
very rarely are they heavily
differentiated in my world I'm like I
want to know what's weird about you you
know do you speak Spanish do you you
know have experience with particular
technology none of that is necessarily
about being passionate you're talking
about hiring yeah for sure when I talk
to Young coaches in this field I'm
always like figure out what you can do
to be differentiated and very rarely
does following your passion get you
there because everybody in my field you
have to remember most people wind up in
this world because they like to exercise
or they were former athletes that wanted
to stay competitive but it's not a
differentiator it's just something that
they're passionate about and I think you
quickly realize when you you open a
training facility that some days it's
not much different than you know running
a restaurant or a you know accounting
firm or something like that so I think
where I've been served well is I always
try to actually develop skills that that
could in one way or another make me
differentiated in the marketplace makes
a whole lot of sense passion does not
automatically equal differentiated for
sure you still need to have it but you
still need to have it it's not the most
important I'd say what if you changed
your mind about in the last few years
and why I'll give you two the first one
I would say is isometrics and I think
for those who don't know isometric is
really just a muscular activation where
there's no change in length so if I had
Tim hold in the bottom of a split squat
for 30 seconds that would be an
isometric hold and I always thought that
hey the loading isn't significant enough
I'm not sure this really has its place
and we started to see more benefit I
think with respect to really hyper
mobile athletes people who are really
really loose jointed giving them time to
own positions really helpful but what
really took me to the next level was um
Dr Keith Barr's research is excellent
he's looked a lot at the favorable
impacts of isometric holds on on Tenon
Health particularly with respect to
Achilles and patellar tendons and it
just seems like the biochemical response
to isometric loading is really really
good and it does things that we we don't
get from concentric or eccentric do you
have any idea why that is that's a lot
of what his research is has kind of
postulated but it seems like 30 seconds
is kind of like a minimum threshold so
we've seen some really really awesome
changes in some of those chronic
patellar tendinopathy people chronic
Achilles tendinopathy people where we
even use it proactively like start of
the off season we want to do some more
isometric loading for people as we
prepare them for their off-season Sprint
programs and things like that so I think
that's powerful I think the next step is
how do we translate that to maybe
tendons that aren't as easily measured
so the example would be like you can
touch your patellar time you can touch
your Achilles tendon it's really hard to
say like all right I want to get in on
my
superspinatus tendon and we know in a in
a baseball world like some of those get
pretty banged up over the course time is
there something that we can do to
favorably impact tendons that maybe
aren't as easy to isolate so I do think
that's kind of like an exciting Frontier
and you know credit to Keith and his lab
for doing some great work so I'll be the
first one I think the second one is
hanging in general I was kind of out on
hanging for a long time even though it's
very evolutionary if you really think
about it it makes sense like holding
onto a pull-up Barn
yeah and I think maybe my bias came
because we see a lot of really hyper
mobile loose jointed folks in the
baseball world and they can just get in
really really bad positions so when they
hang you usually see like elbow
hyperextension you see like a ball
that's like flying out of the socket in
the shoulder and so I really didn't like
the idea of doing a lot of it with them
but I quickly came to realize is if you
have any athlete that has like any
element of stiffness things like that it
does seem to really make a big big
difference so particularly when you
integrate hanging with correct breathing
understanding how to inhale and exhale
correctly where you actually can
manipulate how you're you're
pressurizing the rib cage that has been
I think a big difference maker Force
particularly with how people are very
dense through their lats and you get
your arms overhead you hang
you get some reduction in tone there and
you can also deload it there's nothing
that says you have to hang with your
full body weight you can you know put
your feet on a box and you know cut 50
of your body weight out so I'd say if I
had to change if I have the if I'm
changing two areas over the last couple
years isometrics and utilizing more
hanging variations so quick side Notes
One
this is maybe neither here nor there
Bruce Lee a huge fan of isometrics and
he was really a sort of high neural
Drive connective tissue guy with a lot
of what he did and then the second is
a question about the hanging what might
a protocol look like for your athletes
how long are they doing and then what is
the correct breathing I'd say for me I'm
generally integrating in the warm-up
particularly in someone who's really
Limited in shoulder flexion so their
ability to get their arm overhead so
I'll generally program it for breaths so
I might only have him do five breaths
and again usually it'll be like a like a
lad inhibition hangs we might not have
you know full percentage of their body
weight but you know we have other
variations that are just like hanging
they're all they're ultimately
distraction exercises for the upper
extremity that are effectively taking
the rib cage away from the pelvis right
so you're getting some length through
quadratus laborum and Latin and long
hand of the triceps all these different
muscles that kind of all run in that
same path so five breaths and it might
be an inhale to the count of three and
an exhale to the count of six so you're
talking about these taking close to a
minute so that's why you know full body
weight might not be necessary how we cue
their breathing will kind of be impacted
by some of the infractional angle stuff
that I talked about a little bit maybe a
really forceful exhale for like a wide
Isa that really needs to learn
Isa is infrastrol angle sorry versus
like a narrow it might be more like a
inhale through the nose and try to
expand your rib cage to the sides and
then when you exhale think of like
fogging up the mirror versus like
blowing out the birthday candles so
subtleties that we would obviously coach
in different positions and we might use
that more in one than the other but yeah
definitely just some different ways that
we'll attack it amazing well Eric I mean
we have a million different things we
could talk about I don't know since you
mentioned the book Upstream from Dan
Heath was it Dan was the one that wrote
that one correct yeah Dan he's would you
like to speak to some of the Upstream
variables that people might want to pay
attention to in your world
a couple big ones I would say first
don't specialize young I mean that's a
message for both the parents on this
podcast but also I think people who may
be losing athletic initiatives in their
life like try to find a way to do a wide
variety of movements well into adulthood
so that's certainly an upstream activity
because it's much easier to do a little
bit maintain Mobility than it is to lose
it and try to get it back it takes a lot
more work I think obviously sleep
nutrition and regular movement are very
very big certainly there are times when
supplementation can make a big
difference we know that you know vitamin
D deficiency seems to have some pretty
big relationships to the musculoskeletal
Health as well I think in the big
picture of movement if we're going to
look underneath that Umbrella Just pause
for anybody wondering that is my dog
Molly timing her Extremely Loud water
intake perfectly with whenever I'm
recording man's best friend I'm a big
fan yeah but I think underneath the
movement umbrella optimizing rotation
seems to be the one that's really really
big I think we get really really kind of
stuck in this sagittal plain world
everything is very strange to fun what
that means so the sagittal plan would be
straight ahead play so forward and back
you know so if you've got to paint a
glass like going through imagine the
middle of your head that's a that's a
sagittal plane movement you know a
frontal plane would be side to side so
like a lateral lunge or like a shuffle
to the side and then the transverse
plane is I think where people get in
trouble that's rotational so imagine you
know rotating through a med ball or the
rotation that takes place during a golf
swing or tennis baseball swing something
like that yeah and I think in general
people lose rotational capacity but it's
actually vitally important we use it
probably a lot more than we could have
possibly recognized that's something
that we need to be really really mindful
of for sure I'd say watch for anything
that snowballs for you right like if you
had a non-ideal pattern and then you go
and you throw 500 pounds on your back
and try to back squat bad idea yeah
loading bad patterns generally magnifies
it but I would even argue that load
doesn't just have to be weight on a
barbell right load could be going out
running full speed when you're you're
hips barking at you or you have you know
an Achilles tendinopathy or something to
that effect
um anytime you start to load
dysfunctional patterns I use that term
very Loosely because we're still I think
in an industry unable to perfectly
Define what that is but you know pushing
through pain generally doesn't end
really really well and then the last one
I'll say this is kind of an interesting
methodology one that I might be starting
an entirely new discussion as we work to
wrap up but I think you always want to
know why you're stretching something so
don't just stretch something because
it's tight stretch because you have an
actual rationale for doing so but if you
add motor control if you had to if you
looked at good stiffness to a situation
you'll almost never go wrong but you can
make yourself a lot worse if you stretch
the wrong thing could you give an
example of a rationale and adding
stiffness let's talk about tight
hamstrings because that's probably the
tightness that we encounter the absolute
most so your hamstrings can be tight for
a lot of reasons it could be tight
because the muscles are actually
fundamentally short it would be really
really hard for that to happen just
because they cross multiple joints they
extend the hip they Flex the knee like
you just don't live in that position to
actually be shortened enough so more
often than not what we see in the
hamstrings actually a protective tension
our pelvis is really tipped forward our
hamstrings posteriorly tilt the pelvis
so they're firing on all cylinders and
many of our really you know kind of
active extension bias athletes to kind
of prevent and debilitating low back
pain so that tone is there for a reason
so if we stretch it out sometimes we
leave them transiently unstable in a
little bit of a position of exposure
likewise you could have hamstrings
tension because you blow out a disc in
your low back you have some kind of
nerve tension maybe you pulled a hammy
and the there's just like an element of
that that tissue not just realigned the
right way so it's kind of dense and
fibrotic and nasty so we just go and we
stretch aggressively we're not always
taking into account what could cause
that conversely you add some stability
to the system so in the case of like a
protective tension maybe you give them a
little bit of core control you give them
some glute activation teach them how to
post really tilt their pelvis and all of
a sudden that tension kind of can
resolve so I'm always mindful of don't
just stretch something because you think
you need to stretch because you know
exactly why it needs to be stretched and
more important look to add good
stiffness motor control somewhere else
and this is why some people go to yoga
class and feel amazing and then every
once in a while you get someone that
just feels way worse when they left
they've probably stretched out some
productive tension or they they hung out
on on a structure that didn't want to be
hung out on
how would you suggest people
learn more about this the reasons for
stretching versus not stretching how to
forensically analyze what they're
experiencing to determine whether they
should stretch or not are there any
researchers exercise physios
or otherwise who's thinking you respect
on this and the actionable items for
folks I think this is why it's important
to have like good practitioners helping
you I think in general we can probably
both agree like you need a contract
written up you go to a lawyer you need
an MRI done you go to a doctor or you do
your taxes done you go to an accountant
but anybody who's ever walked into a
commercial gym will kind of see that
people tend to throw a bunch of poop on
the wall to see what sticks when it
comes to exercise and and scary because
you screw up your taxes there's a way
out of it you screw up your body you
might have a lifetime of pain so I do
think in general escalating things to
qualified professionals is helpful
that's very hard because it's a low
barrier to entry industry we could go on
online and get your dog certified as a
personal trainer this afternoon if we
wanted to and I think that is a problem
is that licensure really isn't a thing
so there are some kind of fly-by-night
operations that are challenging so
that's a great question I'd have to
really stew on it because I think it's
such a multi-faceted discussion that we
really need to dig in on let's talk a
little bit about
separating the charlatans from the
legitimate practitioners what are some
questions people might look for elements
things that are lacking or present that
would be
not necessarily definitive but possibly
indicative of good or bad so for
instance
for me when people ask me about various
facilitators or researchers who are
conducting clinical trials related to
say psychedelic compounds the best
people in almost all the universities
certainly will have comprehensive
medical intake and so what I tell people
is look I recognize that saying just say
no to drugs may not work like just
abstain is not necessarily going to
convince everyone so for those people
who are going to try to self-navigate at
the very least anyone you consider
working with should without your
prompting take you through a very
comprehensive medical intake just as one
example what prescription medications
are you taking yeah as one example what
are perhaps some of the things people
can look for or look out for with
respect to the good and bad players or
the trip wires yeah yeah exactly you
know when that always blows me away I'll
go on the road here and there and work
at it at random gems and I'm always
amazed when I walk into a gym and they
don't have you sign a waiver that just
to me is a sign that there could be so
many other things that are going on
there that that just like that's the
most buttoned up thing you can possibly
do is that yeah if they're missing that
checklist because when you do that
that's your emergency contact info you
know so if you walk into a random gym
and on the middle of Kansas or whatever
to get a workout in and you know you're
not filling that stuff up you're a
diabetic and you know you collapse in
the middle of your sesh they should have
all of your information on file so that
they can call your you know emergency
contact and find out oh he's he's a
diabetic that's the first thing that you
tell the ambulance when they arrive all
those things so I'm always astounded
that that happens and I think often
that's because you know it's usually
like a 16 year old kid at the desk and
you know there's your standards aren't
help but then you have to ask yourself
all right is this equipment been
serviced correctly are these bands
broken is this cable going to snap while
I'm working out like those are you know
some of the very realistic you know kind
of challenges those legitimate concerns
too I've seen some horrifying videos of
people working on pulley systems and the
cables just snap because they're not
maintained yeah having run facilities we
have that it's all very itemized in
terms of how often we check it and I
want to know that anytime something goes
on that we have like a media contact
info for everyone so that's you know I
think that's maybe not where you're
going with it it was more with
respective that's super helpful but I do
think I mean the certification is
obviously like a minimum threshold for
working with people and like I talked
about earlier with practitioners you
want to look at people that have been
exposed to a wide variety of
philosophies I think that's helpful
understanding like what a typical
session looks like if it's like all
right they come in they ride the bike
for 5 minutes and then we like press and
you know do pec deck flies and stuff
like that it's probably not someone
that's going to be an ideal fit for like
teaching you how to move better so you
know when I see people that have a
little bit more movement competency
emphasis to this that's important I
think it's vitally important to consider
too like the people that are probably
listening this podcast are not going to
be the um the one percent that are
trying to like compete as bodybuilders
or you know in some cases be you know
high high level power lifters we're
talking about folks who are looking to
to exercise to improve their quality of
life and to reduce the incidence of pain
and all these different things so you
want someone that has a little bit more
of a movement competency so I look for
things in that realm like an awareness
of you know how we can actually optimize
movement quality so not to invite you to
put your foot in a bear trap but I will
any certifications that you find more
compelling than others if someone's
looking for someone to help them with
the types of things that we're
discussing in this conversation and a
word no okay and that's a sad commentary
on our industry and I think it's really
really hard because so many people have
kind of flocked to that world don't get
me wrong there's stuff the nsca has
obviously been been looked at as like
kind of the gold standard the cscs and
you know I do think that's a critical
threshold because it at least verifies
that your first aid into CPR certified
and you know you have some awareness of
how to design a training facility and
some of those things but I think if you
talk to most people that are having
success in this industry and they're
they're coming back they're saying that
most of what I learned I learned on the
Fly I didn't learn it from my
certification I didn't even learn that
much from my undergraduate exercise
science degree in many cases and then
and I think that's challenging I do
think there's some people that have have
put out certifications that tend to be
very specialized in various ways on a
wide variety of topics but I don't know
that there is one certification out
there that really heavily differentiates
really well I think Mike Boyle's done a
great job with the certified functional
strength coach certification people that
are that are doing that are certainly
like above the the basic professional
Mike Robertson certification is
excellent as well but I'm still not sure
that certification is enough in our
industry to like really uphold this
really high standard because you can do
it in a day you can't do med school in a
day my wife is actually an optometrist
and she always is remarked about this
she's like you know she did four years
of undergraduate school it was a
biochemistry major four years of
optometry school and then she went at a
one-year residency in Corny and contact
lens and she's like I spent nine years
on eyes and like people in your industry
go to a weekend certification and they
get a whole body like is pretty eye-op
there for lack of the pun but it's
something that I think we need to be
better on and it's good for Motivated
people that want to make a difference
because it is a low barrier entry but
it's it's also bad for unmotivated
people that want to enter an industry
that can profoundly impact people's
lives really quickly too yeah totally
Eric we keep going for hours is there
anything else that we have perhaps
omitted or I'll take the blame for that
that I have omitted
that would make sense to talk about and
there are many notes in front of me we
could talk about any number of things I
think you've done a wonderful job which
is expected in light of of how long
you've been doing this so I think
probably the best place we can finish is
me thanking you because you've done a a
great service to the to the body of
knowledge by supporting so many
different initiatives in this realm for
a long time so I commend you for all of
your great work well thanks Eric well I
really appreciate that and
I think we're maybe we could try to wrap
up it's very comedy to say and looking
forward to
getting unbroken
I do periodically smash Humpty Dumpty
into a million pieces and then he needs
to be put back together again
let me read a name and maybe this will
be a good place to begin to wrap up
maybe not we can decide
so B in quotation marks is it brijesh
Patel oh yeah
what did you learn from this person who
is that and my daughter so funny story I
got accepted to the University of
Connecticut graduate school early in the
summer of 2003 and I went to UConn not
knowing what I really wanted to do
underneath this Kinesiology umbrella I
thought maybe I wanted to get into
research and all that stuff and it was
just when I had started doing some
writing in kind of like an online medium
and uh brijesh at the time was a
graduate assistant strengthy Edition
coach at the University of Connecticut
and what brijesh did was he actually
read a couple of my articles and so I
got to campus we had some graduate
classes together he had several teams at
UConn that were underneath his umbrella
and he said hey man if you ever want to
come in and Coach like or just observe
just say the word it's like oh awesome
he's like all right men's baseball's at
5 30 a.m tomorrow morning I look back
and he was a million percent like
testing me and sure enough I I got up at
five I showed up and I watched it and it
literally changed my career in that
moment because I saw the way that he
commanded a room I saw the way that the
players bought into everything he said
in that moment I got complete really
hooked on strange editioning and you
know at the time I was taking organic
chemistry with a class of like 250
undergraduates and I saw what brijesh
did and none of that his focus on
movement competency and things like that
it was just a different way of training
people but also a different way of
impacting athletes which I thought was
great
what made him different or notable for
you and how he interacted with his
athletes or commanded their attention I
think the biggest thing was how he could
be two different people in the best way
possible you know there's the old saying
they don't care much you know until they
know how much you care and would rajashi
could be very business-like and in front
of a crowd when you need to be very
organized and locked in and control the
room so that everything Could Happen
efficiently but then I also saw the
relationships that he had on the side
how he knew literally everything there
was to know about every athlete he
clearly grasped them on a personal level
and things like that I'm interesting we
only got probably six months together he
actually moved on took a job at the
College of the Holy Cross he actually
just won a national championship with
Quinnipiac in in hockey but looking back
like that was the reason I went into
strain the auditioning instead of
something else underneath that umbrella
and I was very lucky to have very good
mentors at UConn him and Tina Murray
who's now with the Pittsburgh Penguins
and Chris West and under the soccer
umbrella and Andrew hoodoo who's back at
UConn there were just some some amazing
coaches that really really helped me out
her
is there looking forward anything in
particular that you would be excited to
work on in the next handful of years
that maybe you're not working on now or
could be an extension of something
you're working on so baseball is in a
challenging place right now as we we
talked about a little earlier you know
average fastball velocity has has surged
like there is very much this injury
epidemic in baseball and I think the
challenging thing is that we hear about
it at the major league level and the
stakes are the highest but we're
realizing more and more most of the
athletes are very broken at Young levels
I look at Radiology report after
Radiology report on 18 year old elbows
and so many kids are blowing out at
Young ages and they're broken before
they even know they're broken and they
just they get to higher levels and
that's when they eventually start to
kind of hit a wall so I think really the
big picture is what excites me the most
is how do we favorably impact what's
happening on the youth side of things to
make sure that the next generation of
really talented players are are healthy
because we're getting to a point where
Sports Medicine really can't keep up
with you know 16 year old kids that are
throwing 100 miles an hour that never
happened in the past so I think big
picture it's the interaction between
sports science Sports Medicine and
strength conditioning biomechanics
mental skills it's how all those
different pieces fit together it's a lot
of the stuff I'm kind of tasked with on
a daily basis in my role so that's
what's really exciting is how do we make
this better for the next Generation Eric
thank you so much for the time I always
enjoy our conversations and people can
find you in many different places so
Cressy sportsperformance.com just to
remind people on spelling that's
c-r-e-s-s-e-y
ericcresty.com
and we'll link to all the social as well
are you more active on any particular
social than any other let's say probably
Twitter and Instagram okay so Twitter is
at Eric Cressy and Instagram also at
Eric Cressy thank you so much for taking
the time thanks for having me this is a
lot of fun I really really appreciate it
and I can't wait to get hands on and
everybody listening you can find show
notes links to everything we discussed
as usual at tim.blog slash podcast that
includes transcripts and so on and until
next time be just a little bit Kinder
than is necessary to others and to
yourself and as always thanks for tuning
in
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
Aeropress I love Aeropress with more
than 45
000 5 Star reviews and customers in more
than 60 countries it might be the
highest rated coffee maker on the planet
let's rewind just a bit because back in
2010 2011 I tested the entire gamut of
coffee brewing and filtering options
alongside a former Barista world
champion this was for research for the
four hour Chef that concluded with a
statement that the Aeropress was quote
far none my favorite Brewing method end
quote I even mentioned it and made a cup
of coffee on Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon using the Aeropress here is the
back back story remember the aerobi the
amazing ufo-like disc that you could
throw farther than a football field Alan
Adler a mechanical engineer and Stanford
University lecturer created that then
after Conquering the 1980s toy Market he
began to obsess over one thing coffee
the result was the Aeropress which
debuted in 2006 it was quickly adopted
by the specialty coffee community and it
became so popular with the Barista
community that someone in Oslo Norway
started a world Aeropress Championship
because the Aeropress combines the best
of three Brewing methods you get a cup
that is full-bodied like a French press
smooth and complex as if you were using
a pour over method and rich in flavor
like espresso best of all it's super
small you can pack it in your bag when
you travel it takes literally five
seconds to clean it is all practical no
fuss and you don't have to drink
mediocre coffee at your office or Airbnb
and now they have a new crystal clear
version Sleek enough for display and
Tough Enough for the road you can pick
one up at aeropress.com Tim that's a e r
o p r e s s.com slash Tim for less than
fifty dollars that's aeropress.com Tim
and my listeners that's you guys can get
15 off just use the link aeropress.com
Tim I highly encourage you to try it out
you will not be disappointed
aeropress.com Tim
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all that ad
nauseam but now I am falling asleep in
record time why because I'm using a
device it was recommended to be by
friends called the Pod cover by eight
sleep the Pod cover fits on any mattress
and allows you to adjust the temperature
of your sleeping environment providing
the optimal temperature that gets you
the best night's sleep with the Pod
covers Dual Zone temperature control you
and your partner can set your sides of
the bed to as cool as 55 degrees or as
hot as 110 degrees I think generally in
my experience my partners prefer the
high side and I like to sleep very very
cool so stop fighting this helps based
on your Biometrics environment and sleep
stages the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wake-ups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its testing class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable so go to
agesleep.com Tim for 300 off the Pod
cover through June 6th stay cool this
summer with eight sleep now shipping
within the US Canada the UK select
countries in the EU and Australia that's
eightsleep.com Tim spelled out
e-i-g-h-t-sleep.com Tim for 300 off
foreign
[Applause]